so we got we got some crazy news but
we've got some breaking news i guess
kyle rittenhouse has been released on
bail
and we've got some we got we got the uh
the just that story
i guess he's out uh he's not proven not
guilt or anything like that but he's out
on bail and
we learned about his gun and the like
the weird he bought a gun with a
covid check or something like that so
we'll talk about that we got some other
weird story so apparently
i don't know this is weird at all it
might be totally normal but people are
kind of spreading rumors because
there's been new supreme court
assignments as of today
for the circuits and amy coney barrett
was basically placed
uh in charge of wisconsin and brett
kavanaugh is now in charge of
pennsylvania which is very convenient
for donald trump so
we're talking about this keep the intro
short this time but we're joined by the
one and only hotep jesus
tim cash how's it going man mr tim poole
what up life is good man thank you for
having me i appreciate you
man um i made sure let them hear that in
the mic
brought you a beanie man oh you brought
me a beanie hotep nation beanie
oh my gosh it's amazing i couldn't i
couldn't let you walk around this earth
and not have an alternative beanie
correction and and and here's a hotep
nation
lanyard yeah right on man wow thanks
dude no one's ever has anybody given me
something on the show like that i don't
think so
well it's super awesome comes bearing
gifts right yeah i love it
right on dude so uh yeah what's up
um we got a lot to talk about for sure
yeah
your friend over here say your name and
one yeah ian crossland ian crossland
thank you
pleasure to meet you too man you asked
me what does hotep mean yeah
okay so i'm going to tell you so hotep
is an ancient meta network word or
ancient comedian or ancient egyptian
this is the language they spoke in
ancient egypt
and hotep meant peace or satisfaction to
be at rest and there's like nine other
definitions
so where should we start the story okay
how did i become hotep jesus let's just
get this
knocked out the way now so right around
the time that mike brown trayvon martin
and all those guys get murdered right
um there became this like clear divide
between the black left
and us at this time this is like
is us the hotep or what hoteps yes at
this time i didn't know what a
conservative was let alone a black
conservative
so when i found out about conservatives
i was like they got black conservatives
wow this is
pretty cool so um it became
hotep was a pejorative it became like a
word of slander
hoteps can loosely be described as the
conservative arm of the black community
right interesting we're so called the
consciousness of the black community
they kind of push us to the side and
land bastas and we're the step children
but we're the ones that give
give them their consciousness that word
melanin that they love to run and walk
around with
yeah our ancestors our hotep ancestors
were the ones that put that on their
desk
we're the ones that placed that
memorandum there um
so yeah so they made it a pejorative and
then i was at the time i had went
through a real spiritual awakening so i
was speaking i was tweeting very
spiritually
and uh some troll was like what do you
think you are some sort of hotep jesus
and i was like damn that has a ring to
it yes i do yeah so i was like you know
what
yeah i do think i'm hotel jesus and then
the star was born
right on that's cool so uh we're also
hanging out ian of course yes hello
and uh yeah make sure you subscribe hit
the like button hit that notification
bell shows live on friday at 8pm but
let's let's let's jump right into it
that's interesting you're talking about
like the black lives matter stuff like
michael brown and trayvon martin was the
start of
what uh what it started black lives
matter so this breaking news we got
let's just do the breaking news first
because this is particularly relevant
kyle rittenhouse released from kenosha
county jail
after bond posted it's it's pretty
straightforward that's the story right
so you know but those little details
they say that the teen was fatally
charged with shooting two protesters in
kenosha
many of you probably know about this
this was in wisconsin he is no longer in
custody at the kenosha county jail a
spokesperson for the sheriff said in a
statement uh
kenosha county prosecutors charged
written an uh of antioch illinois with
fatally shooting joseph rosenbaum and
anthony huber
during a protest uh over a police
shooting in august they've also charged
him with wounding a third man
gage grassroots rittenhouse faces
multiple counts including intentional
homicide and illegally possessing
a gun his attorneys contend he was
acting in self-defense
the case has been a rallying point for
conservatives yeah we don't need that
stuff
they say in a phone interview with the
washington post rittenhouse revealed the
gun he used in the shooting was
purchased using money he received
from an unemployment check during the
coronavirus pandemic
basically his coveted stimulus check he
used to buy a gun smart man
written i'd say i mean he's in a hot
he's in hot water right now but
right now 17 could not legally purchase
the weapon himself so he gave the money
to a friend to buy it for him according
to both written house and police reports
that's crazy that's messed up
he says i got my twelve hundred dollars
from the coronavirus illinois
unemployment
because i was on furlough from the ymca
i got my first unemployment check so i
was like oh i'll use it to buy it he
told the post
prosecutors have charged a wisconsin man
with supplying the gun that's crazy
in his interview right now said he
doesn't regret having the gun that night
saying i had to protect myself i would
have died that night if i didn't
so man i mean there's a breaking news
right off the bat i'd be interested to
hear what you think about kyle
rittenhouse
i like kyle rittenhouse he's a hero wow
he's an american
hero it's a kid who took a stimulus
check
and bought guns yeah but he wasn't
legally allowed to and someone did it
illegally for him that's not cool that's
unconstitutional to put an age on
how old you can be to buy guns and it's
unconstitutional
there was a something recently came out
i can't remember exactly what it was but
they said
that there's a different like the
current supreme court is going to
interpret 2a very differently
i can't remember who i was talking about
this sure but they were like we might
start seeing a bunch of changes to
uh these laws that we got you know in
california they ruled
i think the ninth circuit ruled that uh
magazine size
you can't restrict that that's a
violation the second amendment so we'll
see if that
hits the rest of the country yeah sticks
but there was something like somebody
was telling me i can't remember who they
said that it's likely that with the
supreme court we're going to start
seeing
the nitpicking of all these laws like oh
this thing can't be used but that thing
can't be used
that's going to go away yeah speaking of
unconstitutional
the inevitability of communism
is that what you think it's the
slithering dragon
it's the snake and it just
finds its way into your backyard and
bites your child when you're not looking
that's what it does
they're trying to bite us right now with
the vaccine they're trying to take our
guns away they're trying to take our
speech away
that's what communism does man you know
but uh kyle ridden house
is a hero in my eyes he stood up for
what he believed in
and looking at the video footage of the
shooting
i didn't see a guy purposely trying to
murder somebody
i saw somebody running for his life
saying he was going to the cops saying
he was going to the cops
indeed and there was a bit of a
verbal skirmish at the gas station prior
to
and one of the gentlemen who got his wig
split
he uh said go ahead shoot me mfr
this is what one of those guys said i
think that was rosenbaum wasn't it yes
yeah and then he chased after him then
he chased after him and he got
exactly what he asked for um which is
unfortunate yeah it's unfortunate to
have
anybody lose their life over this
political divide that the media has
created
so you know shouts go to his family and
condolences to them
i just find it ironic that he asked for
it and he got it
you know god speaks in mysterious ways
but kyle rittenhouse i thought he was
defending himself
i think so i think that's clear i think
it's weird that they decided to do like
the harshest possible charges imaginable
to this kid
and then the media went nuts just lying
about everything
yeah i heard them call them everything
from like right wing
to uh conspiracy thank you white
supremacist
i'm like it took out two other white
dudes
and the third guy that got shot was
white it's it's it's
it's just it's the media game man and so
i talk to people all the time they have
no idea what happened
we had uh you know we had the the uh the
people that were actually on the ground
covering it
the riot squad okay so we had you know
like shelby talcott uh richie mcginnis
uh who else is in jorge ventura or
ventura there was one other this is
someone else no i think it was those
three those three yeah yeah
they were actually there watching it all
happen and uh i also talked to
there were there's a bunch of people
that down there that were covering it
the
the rioters lit a dumpster on fire and
tried pushing it into a gas station
and that's what started it all so then
you get there's a video of kyle
rittenhouse running with the fire
extinguisher we don't
know it's like you have to talk to them
who are on the ground but basically him
and these dudes are trying to put these
fires out if they push a dumpster in a
gas station they blow it up that's going
to be real bad
oh yeah but because he did that they
attacked him
and that's the stuff that the media
doesn't talk about they just say you
know facebook
if you i guess if you praise him in any
way facebook like they ban you or
something like that or just
super strict yeah i wouldn't be
surprised if youtube comes after us over
the way we're talking about it
oh yeah let me calm down let me calm
down i mean look if it's
if if if it's true it's true and if you
feel that way you feel that way i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna
lie i'm not gonna throw this kid under
the bus because the media's threatening
to ban me or social media says they'll
ban me
now we gotta tell people what really
happened well the only thing that i
would add to this conversation is that a
bunch of people agree with you
hotep because he raised two million
dollars for bail
that's cool and i don't think that i
came out of his parents pocket that came
from people who really think that he
did it though they fundraise they
crowdfunded it yeah i truly believe that
to be the case
so what do you think about these rides
man so you know like kind of a segue
away from just the specific car written
how stuff we've had
a year of all this all those riots
things have kind of calmed down a little
bit but i think it's gonna
i think it'll light up again depending
on what happens with trump but just in
the context of
you're saying you know the hotep thing
came out of black lives matter there was
like a split
so just your general thoughts man so i
have to give you a history on black
lives matter
that'd be important yeah yeah so that's
going to take us back to
uh what's that city darren seals
ferguson thank you
ferguson this is right outside of saint
louis right yeah
yeah it's part of the st louis county
all right so
uh a brother by the name of darren sills
is a community organizer out there
and uh he was he was right there with
mike brown's mom
you know the night after we shot you
know the whole nine through the whole
whole thing and uh the first night like
i always tell people with these things
the first night is usually very peaceful
it's people demonstrating they're upset
they're marching
they're venting right and then he said
that he saw some white kids pop
up and try to instigate with the police
they would pop up throw stuff at the
police and then disappear into the night
so we saw the precursor to antifa
basically
yeah and i was telling people at the
time that i was like hey you know
there's like
people that are infiltrating these
things
so he did a expose on black lives matter
and he exposed them talk about you know
how they came down
with the media a lot of people were
taking credit for his work and the
organization
that he did and got those people out in
the streets
um and then uh you know he's talking
about those guys were cutting checks
they were sitting up in the house
donations were coming in and none of it
went to ferguson
okay it all went to people's pockets and
these big checks were coming to some of
these
organizers so the organizers getting
paid to just basically protest but none
of it went to the actual community
um and mysteriously he was murdered um
so you know i just liked it every time i
talk about black lives matter history i
got to shout out darren sills
was he was either dude they found him in
the car or was that something yeah
that's crazy story man
yeah cause i i was down there uh a few
days after everything kicked off i was i
was
i was in and out as the court case was
going on and then i remember hearing
a lot of people were pointing out that
some of the og activists were turning up
dead
yeah some people were saying as a grand
conspiracy i'm not saying that i'm just
saying that's that's
that happened to some people sure as
hell look like it yeah i know
yeah but that's tough man how do you
prove something like that
you know i don't i don't touch stuff
like that that's not my job
um i'm sure there's people out there
that that would risk their life to find
out the truth
i think we understand what happened out
there um i think a lot of us understand
the truth
of what happened to darren seals but um
you know repeated
darren sales he was a soldier he was a a
a
you know a true community leader he he
gave back his own money and his own time
to the community
very important black man um and
and if anybody you know who came out to
ferguson and stole money that was
terrible
that's terrible people do that i got a
quick i got a quick story for you man so
i was down there i can't remember which
night it was
but riots erupted a bunch of people
start running into
i think it was a dollar store across the
street i'm not sure smashing the windows
and then a bunch of young uh a bunch of
young dudes from ferguson linked arms in
front of the liquor store
like that's the one where michael brown
went to to stop the rioting
and then i walked i was i was standing
right by there there's another
journalist
and this journalist from al jazeera
asked these guys like what are you doing
and they said the people riding in
destroying our community don't live here
they're coming from outside and they're
destroying everything they're burning
down our buildings
they're like we gotta we live here we
work here these are our stores why are
they doing this
and then what do we get from antifa
writing articles like in defense of
looting
yeah no joke that article became a book
apparently
and so i'm sitting there watching these
guys beg like please don't destroy
our home and these other people come in
they're smashing up everything
and then these you know white upper
class progressives
defend the the villains the people
destroying the community
they're defending themselves like i
always tell people anytime some of this
stuff happens
you have to understand that day one is
going to be looting and that that stuff
is
is somewhat organic uh when you see the
fire
that's usually white antifa you know
what i mean like i always say i
always say you know black folks we might
be kleptomaniacs but
white folks is definitely pyromaniacs
that's my that's my running joke you
know but
when you see the fire usually that's
antifa
um and and people try to identify that
as like black lives matter people say oh
they're burning down their own
neighborhood i'm like
no that's paid protesters an antagonist
that's
bolshevik money dude they're they're
like rich kids
who are bored yeah and i i've dude i'll
tell you this man
i know some people who've got some legit
money
and it's not so much that the people
i've met in these things are i've never
seen anybody who's paid
to do anything like that right but i've
met people who are well off
and fund their friends to go out and do
that indeed
indeed and that's exactly what we see
happening here and
that's the problem with black lives
matter organization like my homie
worksmith said
where the money at where the money at
there's some uh high-profile activists
people keep asking where's money at yeah
where are where's the money where did
the money go over 100 million was raised
i think in just one year alone so i know
they got a big bad sitting somewhere
that money never makes it to the
community that's what happens when you
deal with slimy democrats socialists at
marxists
[Laughter]
you just don't mince words so you're
right
so like uh black lives matter was
raising money through thousand currents
do you know about that it's like they
were raising money through what i think
it's called thousand currents
that's a charity okay and so because
black lives matter didn't have their own
charity
right they used another but but then
those donations are collected through
act blue do you have the
payment mechanism so you had a lot of
people saying that the black lives
matter was money would go was going
straight to joe biden
but it's not no but a percentage of all
that black lives matter money goes to a
fundraising platform for democrats
so they take their fee right so it's not
it's not direct
cash being given to the democrats but
it's funding partly their their
fundraising apparatus yeah i mean take
five percent of 100 million whatever
that is
right i mean look look at look at uh
if you look at the the the fine print
act blue is the payment mechanism so
we're not saying it's going directly but
whatever ack blue money makes off of per
transaction is going to the democratic
party's going to their act blue i think
it's another
like pack or something like that yeah
yeah yeah well so so
this is crazy a percentage of the money
goes to their operations or whatever
right they use it to fund their
operations but they also have some kind
of provision where
if the organization doesn't collect it
then they can disperse it
yes yes exactly yes i saw that too
that's in the fine print that's exactly
that's standard and a lot of these
contracts with these fundraising
it makes sense to be to be fair it makes
sense yeah you can't just have money
floating around doing nothing right
with it yeah you got to put it to work
and then you have to tell people you're
going to
right right yeah um but again you know
where's the money
uh this is this has been the problem
with the black community
um i'm not going to go ahead and slam
them out martin luther king like that on
tim
cass podcast but i mean um
we've never been does that happen back
in the day too yeah man the whole
the whole civil rights movement was a
was a big publicity stunt
what yeah it kind of worked though
didn't it
yeah it worked to destroy us really why
do you think
integration was infiltration interesting
integration was infiltration i go to the
school of thaddeus russell
renegade university and um
he's got he's got all the facts laid out
we we do a tuesday night class about
africa
did you know that w.e.b the boy never
met a black person until he was 20 years
old
i didn't know that that's crazy who is
that he was frank w ebb the boy
you know one of them old heads from like
earl late
late 1800s early 1900s he lived to
a very old age but uh father is
socialist
um sociology uh black guy half but he's
mixed he's mixed
um but yeah you know uh the
integrationists really what happened was
the integrationists
wanted uh well let's talk about what the
independent people wanted independent
black folks said hey look there's money
coming to
from the government to white schools we
want money for our schools and naacp and
all those
sellouts came around and said look we'll
fight for your cause
if you agree to integrate and they said
we don't want to integrate we're
cool with our schools and they're like
nah we're not going to support you
unless you integrate so you know when
people talk about
they like to talk about tulsa and they
like to call it a massacre
it's not a massacre if you fight back
right so
tulsa was not a massacre it was
definitely uh
an attack on black property and black
businesses and black life
but we fought back and and tulsa
survived for 40 years after that attack
that was black wall street right black
wall street
yeah you know some white folks was a
little upset came down and started
acting rowdy
i think they were democrats weren't they
they were dixie cats dixiecrats yeah
yeah you know white liberals um so yeah
so they came down
and you know caused the fuss and they
were dropping bombs from airplanes
yeah it was it got it got really serious
yeah but the point is
uh black wall street doesn't die until
integration
during during a black lives matter
protest i can't remember
which one i think it was in ferguson
there was somebody who wrote a letter it
was a
one of the black activists saying that
they felt desegregation was it was
like a trick it was that what it did was
you had basically parallel economies
that were you know the black community
was flourishing
and then once they got rid of
segregation and integrated then all of a
sudden
it pushed all of my community into and
under
the white community yeah yeah i don't
necessarily agree with with that whole
school of thought but we can talk about
it so i'd love to hear more about what
you think about that well
they that's the succinctly put right
there that's exactly what happened we
became second in somebody else's stuff
instead of first in our stuff
you know like one of the craziest things
they'll say is oh this person is the
first black to
go to the moon or first black to do this
the first
that award should not go to us that
award should go to white folks
congratulations you accepted somebody
other than yourself
and that's what that's kind of like uh
you know a microscopic look at how we're
treated in america or how we're looked
at by the liberal america oh look
it's cool to be second place so here's
your participation trophy
this is it's kind of interesting though
because the only time i've ever heard
the idea about segregation being like uh
or i'm sorry integration being bad in
some capacity
is from the left right but you consider
yourself conservative
no considering myself hotep we have
conservative values though right on okay
yeah i consider myself hotep although we
have conservative values
and i i get along with a lot you know
shout out to sonny johnson you know
shout out to uncle hotel uncle hotep was
the one that taught me about
conservatism and
sonny johnson refined that that school
of thought for me
and and i think she's the best
conservative i've seen period you know
black white or whatever
um but yeah loosely described as
conservative i know a lot of people like
to describe me as that i don't mind it
sometimes but
hotep to the core yeah i think that's a
good way to put it man
it's it's weird how left and right don't
really make sense anymore
i guess nah that's that's the great
divide to divide the people
yeah you know so we don't unite against
the state
you know that's the big thing and that's
why white liberals keep us in the
forefront
you know the the thing about integration
was
it was about turning black people white
they wanted us to be like them they
wanted us to
amalgamate and and assimilate into the
white culture and become culturally
white
and uh whoever whoever assimilates
best does best if we look at people like
you know don lemon you know clean cut
dude he assimilates real well sounds
like a white guy dates a white guy
he assimilates really well uh kamala
harris she assimilates really well
she dates a white man she's married to a
white man
these people assimilate into aoc she
talks all that stuff about white
supremacy but she sleeps a white man
you know these people assimilate into
the culture and it seems like if you
assimilate
for example my hair would not be allowed
right
unless i was hey you know then it'd be
okay
that's so weird but these are democrats
yeah this is kind of like
a heterodox i don't know it's it's weird
it sounds like a lot of what you're
saying
does fit with with a lot of the social
justice you know activists
yeah but then you're coming down hard
and pointing out it's actually the
democrats that are
you know racist or they have no
diversity they scream diversity but they
have none yes
when you talk about you know the
problems in america right and they say
oh you know
unemployment. well who owns all the tech
companies
it's the leftists so if there's if you
don't guys don't have
representation of women guess who's been
making those decisions
white liberal men if you don't have
black people
on your board or or on your team who
made those decisions
some white male liberal y'all in the
world
they say that they're they're they're
doing better now by
stopping the white cis heteronormative
patriarch or whatever
like it's it's these same companies that
are now trying did you hear what they
hear what you just said
say it again this is what white says
heteronormative patriarchy
okay try to be as verbose as possible
because i'm trying to i'm kind of making
fun of them you know
it and and that's very specific i know
that's almost meaningless right it's
exactly it's
so specific that it's meaningless yep
right it's like you're heteronormative
so every other white man's exempt from
the rule
right right right look the point of
saying it is to like it highlights the
absurdity of the of this friendly group
of people
yes because like a regular person is
going to be like i got no idea what you
just said
right you didn't convey any information
to me by saying that weird phrase yeah
if you're not on twitter you wouldn't
know what's going on right exactly we
gotta talk about the main mag of march
to go
from there but yeah when they say
patriarchy
yeah that's exactly what they want to do
they want to destroy the patriarchy for
you
but not for them just like gavin newsom
it's
lockdowns for you but i'm gonna kick it
with the homies
more than once more than once he got
caught twice twice he got caught you
guys know who those people were
that was the california medical advisory
board
i thought that was the funniest thing
i'd heard dude like you got to be joking
it's kind of so obvious what they do
right they lock they they tell you to
lock down nancy pelosi it's a haircut
mayor laurie lifewicko gets a haircut
gavin newsom goes out to eat gets caught
goes out to eat again gets contest it
was just a mistake no they don't care
about you and they're not scared of this
that's what's weird
yeah some animals are more equal than
others
animal farm yeah if you people haven't
read animal farm
make sure you go give that a good
refreshing read it should only take you
about an hour or two if you got add like
me
yeah insane i had the kids read it this
summer but so so you said
you said democrats have no diversity is
that what you're saying there's no
diversity
so what do you mean by that you have to
think a certain way
you have to look a certain way you have
to behave a certain way
and they use skin color as the shield to
pretend they do have diversity
yeah i mean i go on these voice chat
apps and i have
discussions with them and all the black
people sound exactly the same
and then i get in the room when i speak
and i get ostracized
because i'm different because i don't
come from your world
of peace posh polished
white liberalism you know the black
boulet
i mean the people that complain about
racism and white supremacy
have some of the best jobs yeah they
work for cnn
they work for vogue i'm like you guys
have all the jobs
i wish i would have had when i was
younger they were all blue checked up
and verified do you know how far being
verified goes
when you apply for a job really oh yeah
i know you wouldn't know because you
were smart man
well not just because i've you've never
applied for a job using a blue check
right right right yeah i've not applied
for a job in like 10 years
see what i'm saying because you're a
smart man yeah but some some people out
here
you know they want to apply for a job
and they might have dreadlocks
and they might not have that college
degree and they might not have that
verification
but you know what if i had the
verification they might overlook the
degree
yeah they might overlook the line you're
somebody right right yeah you must be
somebody mm-hmm
but i take it man i don't i i went to
the white house wearing this
did you yeah i didn't wear a suit i wore
the beanie in the over and then and the
shirt or whatever it's called branding
that's right it is it is but it's also
uh i think it's it's it's look man this
is america we're we're a country founded
on
a bunch of farmers fighting back against
you know the the the empire whatever
yes so the way i see it is in this
country
we are all equal okay life liberties put
his hat uh
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness and we are all uh uh
i'm i'm brain farting on the uh the line
from the declaration of independence but
uh
you're created in god's image no we're
all created you know with the same
inalienable rights yes so when someone
says this is the white house i say
that's great but
this is not a building designed and
built for in my opinion
the wealthy and does like the wealthy
elites oh
wait no no no we can go back in time and
talk about the wealthy landowners
and their their ideas yeah what they
wanted to do
but what they put forward in these
documents was planting a seed
that said everybody's got a shot um
allegedly now you've got companies like
vanguard and state street
and uh that own like most of the tech
companies so like vanguard
is the biggest investment firm in the
world it owns and it's not an american
well yeah we got
we have i think after a certain amount
of time we became a plutocracy
yeah and now it's just all the rich
people who just dictate what we do
and they they they pay for the laws
they're like dividing us on purpose as
americans
because of these i don't know
financialists i don't know uh
that's what that's what worries me i
don't know if there's like a grand
conspiracy among the ultra rich to be
like here's what we got to do to the
people
i think it's rich people just acting in
their own interests like ultra wealthy
elites and it's a big club and you ain't
in it but i don't think they have like a
meeting where they're like how can we
screw over the rebel today
or like how can we control no i think
it's basically a guy saying i don't want
them coming in my building
so i want this law passed in your city
and they go you got it buddy
and then they they build this system
around there's but there's so many
meetings documented
there's meetings but it's it's an issue
of i guess it's an issue of intent
right are they having there was a there
was a jekyll island meeting
surely you're familiar with the creature
from jekyll island
no what's this i shall say nothing
further that's where they that's where
they wrote up the federal reserve act
the way oh really the way i look at
you know how this country was founded is
that it's really interesting it had
these ideas of liberalism like classical
liberalism freedom liberty individualism
they certainly didn't uh operate under
the purest form of that when
you know this country was founded but
through that we've had numerous
amendments
supreme court uh rulings that have led
to
more equality i guess you can call it
equality but i suppose i i feel like
i feel like the opposite has happened so
explain the further the further we've
progressed as a country the less
equality we've had really
yeah um where is the equality
where do you see the equality well i can
tell you uh
it was my my uh grandparents weren't
legally allowed to be married because
they were different races
and so they had to actually flee because
it was illegal different states
well again that's the problem with the
federal government right so the federal
government
overrides how the states want to operate
right
i believe that every state has the right
to make laws and say look
we don't want these type of people
getting married
cool i'ma leave and go someplace where
we are welcome
this is the the great thing about not
having a communist nation
because then you got the federal
government opens a window for them to
start calling shots and saying you can
do this and you can't do that
we got to leave that window closed you
can't tell the states anything they want
to do
besides i think the only benefit to
having people get married under the
state is some sort of
tax right tax benefits it was different
back in the day
it was different i mean what's stopping
you from getting married under
i don't know why do you need this
state's approval to get married
i agree with you on that right you want
to talk about why the government has
authority
there's a big difference between
legitimate authority and illegitimate
authority too much of government is just
arbitrary we've just okay you're in
charge of this for whatever reason it
doesn't make sense
yeah you wasn't with me sleeping in the
bed you know what i mean
you wasn't hitting that i was hitting
that yeah hey where was you
at you know you took 30 percent from me
ain't giving me nothing back
you're talking about the government yeah
you took 30 percent
for ties and didn't get nothing back
you screwed me i i was screwing her
while you were screwing me
my understanding as i was reading this
thing we mentioned it a day ago a day
ago or so is that
the average person gets more value more
dollar
per dollar value from the government
than they pay in taxes
it's the rich people that pay way more
taxes that basically subsidizes
i've heard that theory before but that
sounds like what you call
uh overeducated speak yeah yeah
either you taking 30 from me or not i
don't care what you doing with everybody
else and the super rich and what they're
subsidizing
are you taking 30 from me because i need
that 30 percent
seriously yeah so you like these trump
tax cuts yeah
even though it's a deferment right you
still got paid later on
which ones the the the tax program well
the
the the kovid one was a deferment right
but but the uh
the actual tax cuts he put in place oh a
few years ago
yeah yeah oh okay okay yeah yeah of
course i mean of course you're gonna
enjoy that right
i operate as a corporation it's it's
really you know the craziest thing to me
is
i don't understand why when it comes to
when i talk to these leftist activists
these progressives
they're talking about taxing the rich
and all that and i'm like okay but you
know how much money that
like do you know where that money goes
when you tax them like there's a lot of
questions you got to ask when they say
when you say tax the rich okay
what taxes are you talking about capital
gains specifically are you talking about
corporate tax
and then where does that money go what
do you do with it because i'll tell you
what like a good chunk of it goes to
blowing up kids in you know foreign
countries
yeah i mean is that something you you
are choosing to pay for you want to buy
it
right i personally don't i mean when you
charge when you when you
when you tax the rich all you're
basically saying is become more savvy
with how you hide your money
yep exactly right so then you wonder why
you can't get jobs in america is because
they're gonna
offshore them to russia india or some
other
third world nation and and and that's
the result they're going to be much
savvier
you know in order to not pay taxes in
america you need a 500 an hour
dollar uh employee i mean um accountant
somebody who has previously worked for
the irs from those other loopholes
that's how you
you perform tax avoidance is different
from tax evasion got tax avoidance so if
you can afford to not pay taxes
you won't pay taxes and you shouldn't i
i do not advocate for the rich to get
taxed
because advocating for the risk to get
taxed means i'm next
no no that's not supposed to be like
that how do you feel about income tax
it shouldn't be taxed at all the first
instance of tax was for what to
subsidize the wars
when was that revolutionary war civil
war
but wasn't that that was bonds though
wasn't it like so in the revolutionary
war they sold bonds
and then i think income tax came at like
the early 1900s they were like we need
more money
they came around they had the federal
reserve they had a stamp tax
yeah yeah stamp act for for a week
that's correct sir
for imported goods it was like a tariff
yeah so you might not have had an
income tax right right right right but
they were taking that out of your assets
they were stealing money from people
some way somehow then you had
the the european powers that were
controlling the script
that were controlling the currency and
that's really what everybody was upset
about that's one thing a lot of people
don't talk about
because you gotta remember they tried
the first national bank then the second
national bank and then the second
national bank was like alright we paid
off all our debts and after the civil
war the north told the south look
whatever debt you got we're not taking
that you better clear your debts before
you come back
and that's how russia uh gave us alaska
and paid off the debt
you know what i'm saying so we bought
that back from russia
for for helping the north i mean is a
lot goes into
you know the financial background of
america
but i mean there's always been some sort
of lien
placed against the american people so
you
let's go back real quick you were
mentioning diversity i want to ask you
we were talking about the democrats
yeah they all think the same they'll act
the same yeah but they just they say
they look different so that's their
diversity
what do you think about the republican
party uh
the republican party uh
they're so boring there's nothing to say
right dude that's the way i feel
like what do they do like like the
really um
i don't i don't i don't know what the
republican party does i i have no
idea what's happening in that world i
could not speak from an educated
platform on the republican party or the
democrat party
all i can tell you is about what i see
manifested in my life
and it seems like the republicans have a
very hands-off attitude
um it seems like they they bow to
the democrats it does for sure right
yeah
from where i'm sitting and it seems like
the democrats really control
the topics of conversation and control
culture the liberals control culture
and uh like i believe uh breitbart said
andrew breitbart you know
said uh politics is downstream from
culture correct yeah right
yeah so they under they they knew that
you know republicans don't have any
culture like they don't they don't
control any cultural institutions right
the republicans are constantly trying to
be liked by democrats
yeah like you see that video of lindsey
graham fist-bumping kamala harris the
other day yeah sort of like he's the
dude who's coming out telling trump to
fight tooth and nail he's gonna donate
money to this but then secretly he walks
up he's like fist bump pad in the back
because these these you know what you
know what it feels like a lot of these
republicans
and there's some good there's some
there's some good populists like you
know
regular conservatives and there's some
democrats yeah but the republican party
it seems like these guys are all just
like the nerdy kids in school
begging to be popular yeah and they
think the democrats are the cool kids so
they're just like we'll do whatever
we'll say whatever you want you know
just tell me what to say and i'll say it
yeah exactly i mean they were all
puppets puppets at the end of the day
you know alex jones came on your
platform um
actually nah my bad i'm thinking of sean
stone i interviewed sean stone on my
platform
and he broke down who was financing the
left for who financing the right and
they from the same family
i'm not naming no names i'm not that
brave does the left has anybody have
anybody funny
funny yeah or funding funny funny funny
oh they got a lot of names i don't say
names that's not what hotep jesus do we
don't say names
you know what i mean yeah because then
people drag you they're like you bring
them up and then
well i might need their money one day
[Laughter]
right honey all right i'm not i'm not
gonna upset see that's the thing man
everybody's like
upset at this power structure right i'm
not
upset at it i'm upset at the people
for for for feeding into it
we don't got to feed into this system we
could go do our own thing and make this
system
obsolete and and these people would be
wondering like
like you asked me like uh shorty asked
me on the way here you know do i vote i
was like nah i don't vote
if i vote i validate the existence of
the state i'm not validating the
existence of this state so i don't vote
so every time y'all go vote y'all
basically telling the government oh
y'all believe in this what we doing okay
come on down here place this vote no
doubt i got
you and you're validating bs proving
you have confidence in the system to
some degree right so like how many times
do you have to get
shafted before you realize
it's not working for you and the problem
is and that's why i'm writing my
upcoming book
you know it's like they don't have any
sense of history
you know i mean people talk about the
founding fathers like i always say the
founder fathers didn't care about you at
all
you know they were not thinking about
you when they wrote declaration
independence and the bill of rights
they're thinking about themselves right
i don't know i don't know if i agree but
let's let's let's talk about it what do
you mean
okay uh in order to uh vote
you had to own land back then but you
know why that was why is that there was
no ids
so somebody walks into a meeting and
says i'm gonna vote and they're like who
are you
i own this piece of land here right here
yeah so it was your way of saying
i live in this community i'm a member of
this community
you know in order to have power you
always need good excuses
yeah and that sounds like a real good
excuse we didn't have id
well you know what everybody has for id
what's that
called a thumb print but back then i
don't think they knew that what come on
tim don't do no prints back in the day
fingerprints are ancient fingerprints
are ancient bro
they used to take candle wax and then
certify a document with candle wax this
is ancient technology
everybody's got an idea it's right here
it's not it's not just about
iding somebody it was about we don't
want someone to vote
in our you know meetings right who
doesn't have a stake
in what happens here yeah that's what
that's what that's what they say
that's what they say but that's not what
the documents say
the documents are supposed to be for all
people
right not just landowners right you
can't just say oh you have to have a
stake in this
that's a good point too because there
were a lot of people who lived in these
areas that didn't own land
you know weren't voting i think you know
you know
you also got people who were drafted in
the wars while the rich were able to pay
their way out
and you know uh you know the 17th
amendment that we do a senate by popular
vote
okay before before uh before the 17th
the states would appoint senators
specifically because
this is not a democracy this country is
not a democracy it's a republic the
founding fathers thought
you've got the house that represents the
will of the people
but the senators are the upper chamber
of better men yeah
literally that's that was what they
would say better men and so that all
changed in the early 1900s
and i think it was probably michael
malus who told me this that uh
maybe it wasn't no i think it was
sheamus actually oh yeah that there were
there were senators who when they passed
the 17th
resigned saying i do not want to be
beholden to the rebel
you know so so originally yeah we did
have
elitism you know we had a lot more of it
this it was crazy to me you know you
know the uk sells the house of lords
they what they sell the house they still
have a house of lords oh yes yes
the upper chamber is just like religious
you know uh ranking people and like
landowners from like of of historic
merit of some sort
yeah and then the other side is the
parliament and then i think no the house
of commons house of commons yeah so
they're all in parliament the house of
commons is just like the regular people
okay so it was supposed to be like that
here yeah the founding fathers were like
we want better men to be appointed by
you know the state and then the house
was the regular people who would come
and you know
talk about the will of the people yeah i
think that i think it's clever because
we're not a democracy
and you don't just want you know all
political power to be in the hands of
just
popular vote right makes sense but
definitely this this idea was
some people are better than others and
that wasn't you know power evenly
distributed like a democracy yeah i mean
it's true
people some people are better than
others that's the right that that means
you're right you're conservative yeah
not a conservative right right wing yeah
so you know michael malus obviously yeah
yeah so he so he asked me he's like the
new right how do you define what left
and right is and he asked
do you think some people are better than
others yeah and i was like yes and he
goes okay i think some people are doing
better than other people but i don't
think that they're just better
like if someone was born into my
situation they'd be literate
you're over you're way overthinking it
so he said the left gives you a speech
the right would say yes i'm obviously on
the left because
but i i said but the the saying yes is
the correct answer
some people are really tall and they can
play basketball really well
and so what what we mean by better
doesn't
if we're just speaking in general terms
oh yeah there's a chess grand master
and there's a guy who can't win at all
so clearly these things exist some
people are better than others
even if it's just one or two people who
are better at playing chess than most
other people than some people are
yeah but yeah that's that's that's how
michael defines separating the
you know yeah i'm a c-level chess player
and there's definitely better people
yeah yeah dude that's that's that's
crazy that makes you right-wing that's
interesting but what was interesting too
is i think
there's a lot of people that are better
than me at like basically everything so
it's basically idealism versus realism
yeah yeah maybe
yeah that's maybe that's it that's
basically what the you know the
conversation comes down to and that's a
problem there's no balance available
well do you think that there should be
an element of government that is
better men and i i use men figuratively
i mean people
the best type of government is no
government yeah i should have should
have figured you'd say
yeah yeah yeah no government um
you gotta let you gotta look what about
what about like fire departments and
police departments
like i like thinking about um when iris
created
the the first fire departments in boston
and in philadelphia
and originally they created fire
departments because they were actually
creating fires
that sounds like us and they were
fighting for so-called equality
so a lot of those things popped up
independently
and were funded independently
[Music]
i think those are great community things
that can happen that don't need
government intervention
i think that there are people in this
world who
know their destiny know their know their
value
and will do a lot of things for free
there are some people who would
die to be a nurse and never take it
never take a scent and feel
some type of way they just enjoy doing
that people are just built like that
so i think things like you know fire
departments are easy to come by
isn't that idealistic though no that's
realistic you know you know the shopping
cart problem you hear this one what's
that
so they say the shopping cart corral
is the perfect test for whether or not
humans can self-govern
you go you go to the supermarket you get
a shopping cart you go to your car
you got the shopping cart next to your
car it takes almost no time to put the
shopping cart in the corral
but you don't get anything for it right
you know it's the right thing to do yeah
but still people will just leave their
shopping cart right there in the middle
of the lot just get in their car and
leave
and so the idea is you could do the
right thing for no reward
that doesn't really affect you at all
ten five ten seconds
but people still choose not to do it
people in america choose to do it
choose you may choose not to do it
choose not to do it right yeah yeah
you could pull another culture out and
you'd see something completely different
sure
yes it's something to say about the
level of human consciousness in america
and the western world
the the the graduation of the ego
right it's very at a very low state at
this point so we have people
who who exist in this system you know
and
time is of the essence in america right
and a lot of that has to do with that 30
percent that get taken out of your check
regarding the fire department i feel
like it's kind of a specialized job you
got to train and learn how to do it and
carry the weight and all that you know
you know the whatever what it takes to
go into a building fight the fire
and uh takes time a lot of time so if
they weren't getting paid
they might not be able to to support
their lives um if it was a private
company you look at like the roman
fire department's pompey's fire
department he had the first fire
department that we know of
and he would go if the building was on
fire go outside with his fire department
and say
pay me you need to extort the people and
the people be like no i'm not gonna pay
you and then you just let their building
burn down yeah
the the original fire departments i
think used to buy an emblem and you'd
put the emblem on your house
okay and then when the fire call was
called in they'd come and they'd see the
emblem say okay it's like a game you're
a subscriber
you talk again you're talking about a
level of low conscious human beings
right you wouldn't have that in in in
some ancient societies you wouldn't have
that problem
you just have a fire department those
people would be taken care of
you know you know it's interesting i was
reading they might get paid you know
have we have we tried private fire
departments in
a local town and what that looks like
and is it possible
if we didn't have to pay 30 percent that
we'd pay maybe 10
to go to some of those services and
those would go directly to those
services
and those and those people might
actually get paid if you've done it
that's what the government has given
them into an anarchist i think we should
build an
app where you get to pick where your
taxes go on a sliding bar and if you
wanted to slide like 17
to the fire department i want to slide
13 to the police department and you
might have minimums like you have to put
at least 20 percent into
each of these but but then you get to
pick and you'll see like the voluntarism
kick
in but why not why not how about then i
add i want the taxes to go to my
uh skate park so when you're you would
put your skate park
it'd be like tinder you'd be like hey
i'm simple i want to go to skate park
people go i like that i'm going to swipe
right and add that's my list of things
that i can fund yeah but then why not
i'll be like i'm going to give two
percent of my taxes to tim's skate park
but then how about
we just take you know hotep's path and
say you can't get any of my 30
at all and just keep it all right yeah
so you should have that option too just
put in your pocket and if i want if i
want to go to skate park i'll show up
your escape pod and give you money
yeah i think you know
man i'm not a big fan of government
authority i think
a lot of it's arbitrary i've seen a lot
of the arbitrary authority put in action
and a lot of people
that play popularity contests to get the
keys to the castle to have that
authority yeah
but i still think you know i'm not an
anarchist i i probably would be
i idealistically i'm like left
libertarian
and then realistically i'm like probably
just a liberal probably just like i
think we need
i think we need some kind of uh mixed
economy some kind of mix system
i think we should take all them terms
and throw them in the trash why is that
because of listen to what you just said
you said when it comes to this i'm this
when it comes to that
oh yeah but i can't explain it right but
let's just
talk about each issue and and say
what our views are and not label it all
right right
because then with those labels come
preconceived notions i think one of the
challenges is that
you look at the brooklyn bridge so i'm
not i'm not a historian on the brooklyn
bridge but my understanding is that i
was put together by a corporation to
build this bridge
right then you're trying to figure out
how to compensate everybody
and so you have this you know this
corporation originally my understanding
was supposed to dissolve after it was
done
yeah it comes you know yeah like toll
roads yeah yeah it exists
but then the bridge comes to exist
forever what do so what what do we do do
we uh
put up a toll for the bridge forever i'm
not saying it's a bad idea i'm asking
a serious question well allegedly the
the
the fee that we paid through tolls was
supposed to be used to build a bridge
and
i believe there was a budget set aside
to maintain a bridge afterwards right
well for sure and then they saw how much
revenue was coming in and they said
why would we stop this money coming in
look at this but so
ignoring the well there you go that's
that's the first problem with government
corruption
yeah so why why kill the golden goose
we're going to keep the money yeah so
what's the next part to it
so uh well i guess is the solution then
we keep the the bridge
under a private corporation and then
just have them
run it with their their interest only in
that you know bridge who built the
bridge
i think i think the brooklyn bridge was
built by like the brooklyn bridge
corporation or something like that
okay i could be wrong i could be wrong
it's like i was reading a plaque outside
of the brooklyn bridge or something
yeah so um i don't know it's a really
tough question
right the capitalist in me says the
corporation should own it
and they should be able to dictate who
can cross it and who can't and if you
don't like their rules don't go to
brooklyn
yeah that's what vanderbilt did with his
railroads but then when he wanted to
stop shipping food into new york he cut
them off and
starved a bunch of people that's usually
oh they also did that with coal and
everything else yeah and then and then
what happens is they nationalize it that
sounds
like exactly what happens you know but
then they also do things like make
growing hemp illegal
right they make things like collecting
rainwater is illegal
well the collecting i wouldn't need your
shipment of food if you let me grow my
own
well the rain the rainwater thing in
some context makes sense
yeah because like if if uh in certain
areas like in suburban neighborhoods
there's rules about not collecting
rainwater having it run off otherwise
you need a you need like a certain
amount of it's just like about
maintaining the the the environment for
everybody that are living really close
together
yeah but uh in a lot of places it makes
literally no sense so the bigger issue i
think is
rules that are made for cities that
affect people who don't live anywhere
near them
well well let me ask you this let's go
back to the railroad right who's going
to protect the railroad
um in general the police i think okay
please work for who federal
where local or federal all right so we
removed them who gonna protect
vanderbilt from the people after he
started yeah he'd have to hire uh
uh see what i'm saying that's why that's
why government
shouldn't be there because what they do
is these corporations set up
and then they pay the government to
protect them protected yeah and then
they have the most elite security force
on the planet
that's that's why you get rid of
government you know you know scenarios
you know what walmart does
right even better huh i don't know
walmart tells their employees
or there was there was i don't know if
this was a widespread thing but i
remember reading about how walmart told
their employees
if you can't afford to work here go on
go on food stamps
it's like you hired people and you're
telling them to get government benefits
to subsidize
their lives yeah that doesn't make sense
yeah i'm not i'm not applaud i tell
you make too much one more time when you
when you apply for
some of these uh right government
assistance they tell you you make too
much
but it's kind of crazy to me that you
have these big corporations
where they're like we're gonna hire you
we pay this much and if you can't afford
it
too bad go ask the government for
subsidies for a subsidy
if the government didn't provide that
they'd say it doesn't exist you have to
pay more money
yeah so the fact that the government
offers it up actually allows these these
big
you know massive corporations to
undercut the the lower class the working
class
yeah yeah you want to know something
crazy
there's progressives that say they want
they want they want a lot of things they
want four day work week right
okay they want shorter shorter days they
want paid vacation
and they want it implemented through
policy and you know how the
some of these things started getting
implemented it wasn't policy it was
donald trump
the economy was booming and then all of
a sudden we started seeing a bunch of
companies say
we're gonna reduce you know hours you
know same salary but now you only work
32
we're going to give you paid vacation
because the economy was doing so well so
the fact that there was just a good
economy resulted in a lot of these
things that improved people's living
yeah i just feel like
you just let uh companies compete for
employees and
you know if this company is treating
their employees better then they compete
like that and say hey look you know i
heard that i heard they're giving four
days over here i want to apply for a job
there
right and then it changes the culture
you know the problem is that's what i'm
interested in
i think the problem is schools more oh
yeah more more more government i guess
is the problem
for sure yeah school is definitely maybe
the number one problem
along with i mean school and media are
kind of like one because
that's the brainwashing the
indoctrination unit
so you mentioned make p make the
businesses compete for employees right
but what happens when the people don't
understand any of these concepts and
just sit there saying why am i broke and
don't do anything about it
so i know i know a bunch of people that
go to school and they think the only way
to survive is to get a job
as if the employer is the supplier of
money is if the employer like makes
money appear out of thin air to give to
you you can make money too same as them
yeah that's that's just one of those
things where you do as i say i mean
you know watch yeah how do you say do as
i do not as i said do as i say not as i
do yeah
no no no actually that's not it rules
for thee but not for me no
watch just watch me do it yeah watch me
do it
and then people will emulate right
because you can talk to somebody and say
hey you should be an entrepreneur all
day
that don't mean they're going to be an
entrepreneur but when they see you do it
they go oh wait i think i can do that
leave by example
thank you lead by example that's that's
what i say i don't try to convince
people without being an entrepreneur
they just see how i'm living and they're
like
yo how do you do that i tell them and i
said join my saturday course
my saturday class or you know i'll
mentor you during the week
but you just got to be that example
that's the problem out here we're doing
too much talking
yeah not enough doing yeah not enough
doing hotep and build
you know i'm pretty concerned with
private military yeah i've talked about
state and the value of the state
yeah because tax isn't where they go
well that definitely that's crazy
that you don't know where your taxes are
going but up until like the 1400s there
was
all mercenary warfare pretty much okay
and it was one mercenary company would
go
burn down a village and then they'd get
hired by the people to go
defend the village that they you know
burn down yeah
so it's just a constant chaos and then
they they develop standing armies to
prevent mercenary
overtakes so we're basically in a world
of standing armies now that are funded
by
taxpayers yeah and i'm afraid that if we
go back to mercenaries
it would be corporate chaos no we we'd
just get the same thing we have now but
except you and i would be able to form a
militia
or become mercenaries but i don't want
to be in a militia right now
well that's useless right now though
there's people in arizona training right
now
i want people to protect me that's as
they're that's who you want that's who
you want protected well
i like specialization and yeah focus my
energy into creating
content you know thought stuff and then
have someone else carry the guns
have someone else grow in the crops yeah
you ever heard you ever heard the
statement about i'd rather be a
a warrior in a garden and a gardener in
the war
yeah yeah okay so i mean my point is
do you want the government to have a
monopoly on violence or not
because as it is the only people that's
allowed to
do this stuff are governments we
or rich people government rich people
because we're allowed to form standing
militias
as part of our own government yeah you
know you know that
private security they'll shove a cop for
you if you pay the right price
yes we've talked about this quite a bit
you can watch videos
where there's like some some dude is
like doing something the cops walk up to
them start yelling and then two
bodyguards shove the cops down
because those bodyguards are like these
guys have so much money they will buy
that police department out you will not
arrest me
absolutely these cops who get paid 30
40k
coming up and messing with a guy who's
worth hundreds of millions or billions
of dollars
and his private security gets they get
paid you know high six figures they're
gonna be like i don't care that's the
life they're gonna take care of my
family if i go to jail
knock the cop down yeah that's crazy
that's how you gotta live out here you
know but
i think there's a lot of people who
could be trained to be armed security
for the people you know lady talk about
like police
you got a kid in in high school who was
the bully well guess what
he's probably a natural guardian he's
probably a natural soldier
so let's put him in training and let's
make him guardian of the community a
bully though
a bully you gotta understand a bully has
sometimes some psychological issues
that maybe started as a as a youth
all he needs a little bit of therapy and
channel that energy into something good
a lot of times you have with disruptive
kids is
they're just not getting attention yeah
right and then
for example um there was this kid who
was bad in school
and what the teacher used to do was she
used to make him the volunteer
and all of a sudden the bad behavior
disappeared but it's because all the
other teachers would ignore him
wouldn't let him volunteer wouldn't let
him get up be the one and sharpen the
pencils or pass out the papers but she
made him a little helper
and now he's an a student yeah it's it's
about understanding human psychology and
people don't want to tackle that you
know i think you're responsible what
you're saying ian
i think you underestimate your ability
you you should be responsible for you
should be a well-rounded person every
capacity you should you should be able
to defend yourself protect yourself
you should be able to be the one who
carries the gun and you can focus on the
things you're more passionate about
but i think you know you wake up you
read you exercise
you make sure you're you're you're
well-rounded with your specialties
you can be a specialist in content
creation doesn't mean you shouldn't be
able to
you know carry heavy things you don't
farm no i don't
no of course not you're specialized sort
of
but i could farm i could farm too but
you don't and i don't because we're
specialized and that's because this
sociological construct of the government
allows us to be specialized but i
actually like farming well i like
chickens there's a lot of stuff i don't
do but you should do hydroponics
yeah we had a garden at the last house
you should just set up like well that
was mostly yeah
you have to you got the skate park
popping up right yeah skate park yeah
so you need another building with just
the hydroponics man that's the future
we were thinking about doing that with
the with the detachable building we have
but
it's all it's there's no light so we
have to like figure out a way to do
something
with like a greenhouse i guess yeah
greenhouse that bad bloom
but dude dude first of all like i am all
about
self-sufficiency you know what i mean
like we're
almost off the grid at this point if you
try and do everything you'll end up
coming up short
and i disagree with things there's
there's there's two specialized
there's two sayings it's an ancient
japanese saying a person who tries to
catch two rabbits will catch neither
right and then there's another saying
that you may have heard jack of all
trades master of young right
you want to know what the real saying is
what's wrong jack of all trades master
uh jack of all trades master of none but
every so often better than a master of
one
that's a full saying so it's it's
you know it depends you know in in a
culture of
all specialists yeah you know that's
what we've become
and we're hyper specialized now it's
like when it comes to building a
computer you've got
like actually components and parts
you've got some people who specialize in
one tiny aspect of like
building the computer right someone
focuses on like developing the plastics
for the casings or whatever
right it used to be like way back in the
day the blacksmith was the guy who would
like
make the thing right now you've got
added you know thousand different
specialties to get that job done
that's actually allowed us to make crazy
new technology and improve things and
but i think there's still fundamentals
that everybody should probably work on
being fit for instance knowing how to
use a gun probably
i think these are important things
there's like basic necessities for life
that's basic necessities for man it's
like knowing how to change a tire
yeah yep just like simple things simple
um and dependent depending on how good
you want to be at them you know but i
think
you know what i tell people i tell
people the one thing you can do right
now is download a survival guide onto
your phone
you might not never need to use it yeah
but yeah but then you
absolutely that's a good idea how many
how many how many stories we heard about
someone went for a walk and then they
got lost in the woods right
so you look pull up your phone and it'll
say oh here's what i do okay cool
i got a wilderness survival merit badge
and boy scouts i'm good out here
there you go man i'm not like
a sycophant for the government for
government daddy to take care of us but
i value some of the the safety that it
provides i guess for the freedom
safety yeah the freedom like what like
um
if i go outside and someone wants to mug
me they'll do that
well not if there's a police officer
standing by that's i don't know
how what are the odds of that and and
people get directed but people get their
square for instance you ever seen andy
no get beat up in front of police
no not in front of police i didn't see
that dude you see the video
of the trump supporters the maga family
yeah they're trying to leave and the
cops stopped them
and made them go into antifa yeah so
look
i like i said i think we need police i
think police serve a function i'm not an
anarchist or anything like that but i
absolutely have no problem criticizing
the cops
we've had way too much this year of cops
just enforcing these unconstitutional
edicts from governors
yeah instead of actually being there to
help the people and protect them
we had these gym owners by the old house
in jersey where they they got arrested
yeah for just working out in a building
yeah these cops didn't care i'm free to
drive
on the freeway without getting hit by
speeding cars because you want the car
speeding
no they say that people tend to
concentrate
more when they speed oh they sure do
people are going different speeds
did you realize that most accidents are
happening like within five minutes of
your house i've heard that yeah
and and like usually like not speeding
yeah but that's because people aren't
going 30 miles an hour differentials on
the freeway because we have speed limits
usually usually people don't crash
because people are speeding
so people that's that's people don't
drive the speed limit
people don't drive the speed limit
they're either the most part they do and
then
under penalty of law no i mean the
people always speed they always be old
and then
everybody's dangerous everybody goes
five seven miles an hour over
maybe i think that's my person and then
what happens is i've done 130 before
it's so delicious i've done 130
in a honda accord
it's not a piece of metal in the car the
car isn't even metal them things is made
out
of
plastic now if you had a lincoln towel
car from the 80s then yeah right
but you know my father was my father was
military he taught me how to drive
but you know i took that that bad boy
down 280
doing 130 when i was like 18 years old
but your concentration your focus is
spiked not i
don't suggest doing that and keep in
mind
but i know how to drive really well you
need a driver you highlight me i'm real
good at driving my brother's actually a
race car driver oh this is this is just
uh like there's different degrees of i
don't know what the
what the term would be but um you've got
people right now who are saying
no one should be allowed to go outside
because i'm scared of covid yeah then
you got other people saying if you're
scared you stay home i'm going to do my
thing
so there's varying degrees of like how
much freedom we should have versus how
much security and i think the difference
is
you're all about total freedom yeah even
if it means you're not going to be
you're going to have people zooming
patch on the highway you're like well
you know i'm free right yeah i'm free
but freedom has a strange definition
like total freedom
means that you're out in the middle of
no
we've created freedom in the united
states by
a military force so we're pretty we're
giving ourselves
freedom like you can walk around outside
without getting jumped and punched in
the middle
that's a cultural thing dude it's
because we have police protection it's
not it is if it was total law
lawlessness
you could also call that freedom i'd go
out there and urinate on your face and
kick you in the teeth and take your
money and no one's going to stop me
i'm free how do you do that with the ak
strapped in my back
yeah right what if i get the jump on you
i mean you if you want to fight
for a living you're going to end up
getting beat down that's just the
problem i don't i don't
think so so i know the problem with you
oh
i know the problem with you you have no
faith in people
i wouldn't say that that's everything
you said today you don't have faith in
people that can make people
drive fast you don't you think that if
the government wasn't there somebody
come
pee on your face people would be hacking
your bank account
you would have no recourse that's but
here's what you listen
when we're talking about being safe in
public that's not police
the police the police most people aren't
crazy outside you know who
you know who hacks your bank account
yeah
seriously so look i think
i don't i don't expect if i'm gonna be
walking on the street the reason
someone's not gonna among me is because
cops exist
that's not true we have the death
penalty people still commit these crimes
we know
we have a lot more i could take you down
the block right now you won't
you won't walk back from yeah the cops
the cops don't give a damn
what if the whole world is like that
that i mean that is easy no that would
be wrong no it's not
that we have order i mean if you're
saying pure chaos are you familiar with
the wild wild west
i mean i know of it yeah was it wild or
was it peaceful
i think it was wild people get scalped
and murdered and shot it was it was
okay everything you just said is a
historical
what do you mean the wild wild west was
actually really peaceful
for who for everybody you'd walk into a
town and everybody was strapped up
you were you the last society they were
a very politician
but hold on they had duels so it was
like genociding the natives no that's
the government
i mean it was that the government
sanctioned that the natives would come
scout people the people would kill it
was uh and it was government
natives were scouting hold on hold on
hold on where'd you get your history
from
tv i guess some of it probably so hold
on hold on hold on dude
what do you think would happen if you
went to like north africa in the middle
east if you went to libya right now
it scalped you walked and walked in
you're talking about going into like i'm
here you're going into
like uh pure chaos not pure chaos but
when you're talking about police right
now
in a heavily developed and peaceful
nation for the most part crime has been
on the decline for several decades
the reason why you're not getting muggle
time is not because cops exist
however i do think cops serve a purpose
in that
they they do and can stop violence and
they deter it
as well so i think but but for the most
part the reason why you're not getting
mugged is because people don't
aren't going to mug you well people are
animals and when they get hungry they go
crazy
so you got to keep them people are
desperate uh poverty breeds crime
and so you know we we we can i don't
know we can figure out ways to solve
cultural issues but for the most part
violent crime has been going down the
existence of police i don't think is
stopping you from getting mugged
because people mug even though there is
a penalty even though there are cops
that can be called it's just that you
know we
we are learning to live a challenge for
you if we removed government what good
would happen
that's a good question if it was just
like no government at all yeah what good
can come from it
i could see when you when you talk about
removing the state
everybody runs to the extremes and the
bad thing that can happen and you can
and the thing is the way the the the
human consciousness is rigged today it's
rigged to automatically go to doubt and
fear this is old napoleon hill
i got one for you what's that if we got
rid of the state right now
non-violent drug offenders could go home
to their families boom
so that's big and i think that should
happen and people are calling on trump
to do it
but he didn't do it all criminals would
maybe yeah for sure if we got rid of the
state all
but the point he was making was name a
good thing did you hear what he just did
though
he turned it into a bad thing he did it
again well if you want to remove prisons
from the equation completely open up all
jails that
wasn't that wasn't the challenge
was if you give me like a box
of nine venomous snakes and a chipmunk
and you're like look how good the chips
look how good the chipmunk is in this
box great i'd be like i'll tell you the
point i'm trying to make
i think there are way too many
non-violent drug offenders who should be
home with their families
and and we want to keep the violent
psych psychopathic
rapists and murderers in prison you know
that man because i think i agree we
should leave the
non-violent i think the people in prison
should have better i think they should
have access to video games i don't
believe
i i'll mess your head up i don't believe
in the prisons
so what do you what do you do when
someone you like serial killer
first of all if you have somebody who's
a known proven serial killer what we do
is we admit
them to a psychotherapy facility
and this is where college kids get to
train
you get to train on these so-called
inmates but they become case studies so
we can learn the brain and learn
behavior more and we introduce these
people to
more nutritious environments right
and when i say nutritious it doesn't
mean you know these four walls that are
super cold and you know you're locked
down for 20
like what does that actually do for the
human mind
now are we going to set this person free
probably not
they're probably going to be imprisoned
imprisoned i would i've removed the word
imprisoned
i don't know what that word is i'd have
to incarcerate it or i would remove
that yeah i would move that down too
much you know dogma comes with that
stuff you know we'd have to think
about it let's say this who would be
imprisoning them though
let's let's list this i mean
these are all these are all great these
are all great questions
right um but what i'm saying is
the institution of prison needs to be
revamped
it needs to be more about rehabilitation
and not imprisonment because the
majority of the people there
aren't there voluntarily they're there
because of circumstance the environment
they were brought up in that's pretty
much the only place they could end up is
in prison
i'll tell you this if we if there was no
state we'd have a lot less serial
killers because everybody would be
strapped
yep the way you put it yeah i say i
think
i think most conservatives are probably
agree with that everybody needs to be
strapped up you know
when you're born when you're born a gun
should come with your diapers
we used to we don't have a lot of
documentation of the past but i think
there were a lot of serial killers in
the past and it was just normal oh dude
yeah
probably people just walked around and
killed violence no one was there to stop
them
yeah yeah we live in a very i was
reading i was reading uh i told this
story before i was at glenn beck's
studio and
he's got these old newspapers just
mounted on the on on the walls
and i was reading one of them and it was
about some guy walked out of a bar
and then some other guy walking to the
bar and took a pistol like mid-1800s and
just put it to his chest and pulled the
trigger
no reason just did it but i'm like that
stuff happens in chicago all the time
man i grew up around all the time you
know no
no no no no no no no no no no no no
that's a that's probably for sure no
it's all the time
yeah it's all the time would mean
non-stop everything every
day every day every day is different
than all the time so
when i say all the time you you are in a
state where
at any point throughout the day it's
gonna happen and it happens almost every
single day so yeah i think it's fair to
say all the time
it's just an extreme statement it's not
accurate no you're just trying to argue
so what's your name one more time i'm
terrible games ian
if i had you on my team you'd be quality
assurance we wouldn't bring you
anything until like me and tim sat down
and i'd be like okay
tear this apart tell me everything wrong
with it right and i think there's a lot
of people that have these
strengths some people are optimists some
people are pessimists i would put you in
a pessimist category
and i would say tim us optimists let's
get together
wait wait wait to be fair ian's usually
optimists i'm usually the pessimist
i'm saying in the context of this of
right first time i'm meeting him and
every time like i said say something
positive and he was like
we're gonna die pissed off right so
you know in the context of this
conversation this is how i'm viewing
yeah
right so i'm like i would take all the
optimists and say
if we didn't have government what good
could happen and we'd paint our flowers
over here
then i'd bring it in and say hey here's
what we got tear it apart then you
write down everything that's wrong with
this and i'd go back to my optimism all
right how do we fix these problems right
yeah and that's how we use each other
but the the thing i i believe is
you have to escape that that that
thinking momentarily
and say i'm not going to think about the
bad that can come because that's too
easy
what's hard is to think about what good
can come
that's hard and the and the system has
been
con has conditioned us to think only
about fear and to think about um
but you know what don't think it is a
system i think it's human evolution
because in order to survive you have to
think about what's bad
you can't really spend a lot of thinking
time thinking about how nice that flower
smelled when there's a saber-toothed
tiger behind you
you know what i'm saying so it's not
even necessarily cultural unless we're
talking about like
there's different points there's a point
to be made there but when we're done
dealing with a media who exasperates
fear
yeah well they know right like yeah like
they take something that's carnal
and then they just set fire to it and
just you know pour gasoline on it they
they gaslight us
you know what you know what the problem
is the problem is the media is giving us
fake hardship yes real hardship is a
good thing
yes like when you get kids who grow up
with snow plow parents who are pushing
all the obstacles out of their way they
grow up they can't survive properly
right then you get these people and the
media screams in their faces non-stop
the orange man is bad
right and then their whole identity
becomes the world is ending the sky is
falling
yeah because they they didn't go look
you know why i don't when trump got
elected i laughed in 2016. i just put my
feet up and i was laughing
yeah because yeah i'd have a youtube
video i'm just laughing for like 10
minutes
because dude i've been through through
hardship to where i'm like this is not
the biggest
saying problem they're like but he's
going to take people's rights away it's
like dude
you do not remember anything about
politics or what goes on
you know nothing about like living in a
city like chicago
these suburb kids think they have it bad
because the tv told them it's true
yeah they need to go out and go camping
for a couple weeks just like get back to
nature and just you know learn how to
start a fire
maybe maybe hunt something no they need
to go to the hood yeah south america
i mean i mean i would say i would say
that the jungle they need to come hang
out in trenton new jersey in the jungles
that's what they need to do they need a
field trip to the hood and come live in
the projects for a few weeks
it's so easy to get hurt in life it's so
easy to die it's so hard to live
and stay healthy like it is takes
everything that we can
this all this i don't think technology
that we've built modern medicine clean
water
fresh air like it's so easy to die and
it's so
easy yeah you could there are so many
things that can kill you in this world
and there's so
there's just like specific ways to live
why are you so negative
well i'm a real i'm realist i used to be
i think it's so easy to live
it is it's not in our world it is
because we have clothing and
food world country capitalism oh you're
saying
in some of the other countries right oh
yeah it's a fight
yeah some places you gotta you know yeah
you're uh
this is this is this is one of the
problems we have as a culture right now
is that we used to have to run full
speed every day and i mean figuratively
to survive
you wake up you work you then as soon as
the sun goes down you're sleeping but
you work non-stop all day every day
so check this out you keep talking about
all these people in this country to have
a lower life expectancy rate right it's
cause it is iphone
it's cause of our freedom our the cost
of our freedom is somebody else's
freedom
what do you mean that's true the cost of
united states freedom
is somebody all right so whatever
snickers you got on slaves in china the
slaves in china
our technology the slaves that's mining
the coltan
the slaves that's mining the gold
there's always going to be somebody's
freedom that's taken
for yours well for your luxury because
we don't need the phone you you can go
live in the middle of the woods and you
know make a mud hut
you could you could but it's easier not
to
right very a lot easier not to this is
that's a very hard life to live
this is what's funny about when people
criticize the left saying things like
you use an iphone you use his computer
right and they then they have this comic
where they're like oh i'll partici you
know
participate in society or whatever some
stupid comic yeah they think that
they're allowed to use these things that
cause suffering around the world because
they're more effective and better off
with them they don't understand
that you want to complain about the
millionaires the billionaires the big
corporations the exploitation
you want to complain about capitalism
and then use all of the fruits
of how capitalism enriches your life and
makes it easier yeah but you choose to
do it at any point you could say
no they don't want to they don't want to
they want the luxury they want the
luxury they want to complain about it to
see them like
you know what it is it's guilt they're
like i feel really bad that the people
at the foxconn labs are walking off the
building in mass suicide
yeah i'll complain about it but i'll
keep using the phone yeah that's why i
tell people like
when people say oh i love america i'm
like you don't love america you love the
luxury of america yeah
you love the fact that you know we we
take a dump in water
right yeah like that's what you love you
love that running water you love that
electricity you love that wi-fi
you love that beer you love that bread
and circus fast food man
yeah that's what you love you love the
luxury of america
you love the fact that we don't got to
deal with mosquitoes like that and if we
did we could just buy a can of
off yup yup the conveniences of living
in america
but all of that comes at the expense of
somebody else's freedom man
or it comes at the expense of nature
but we're trying to change that like one
of the okay one of the big moves or i
think one of the big drivers of
you know trump's base is bringing
manufacturing and
and back to america and yeah becoming
more reliant on ourselves and our
community
yes brilliant brilliant thing to do
donald trump's the best president we've
ever had
do you think so he's the best president
we've ever had at least in my lifetime
yeah i think that's a fair point
actually you know at least in my
lifetime there's a lot of things he was
bad about
in terms of character and demeanor but
in terms of these past couple years
we're dealing with
pulling our troops out and that to me
was like great on foreign wars amazing
right wow we could do that i didn't even
know that was a possibility
that was just a thing that happened like
america would slip and fall and drop a
missile on you know foreign countries
yeah yeah and we were close to it
because he brought bolton
bolton right we'd be celebrating in
tehran yeah
i mean uh i think i want to say under
clinton
and maybe even bush um you know the
the 90 late 90s and the early 2000s was
kind of good man you could leave a job
and walk
right into another one economy was
coming in too
great great economy the economy ain't
looked that well in a long time
no uh under trump it was better it was
yeah to quote jim cramer i mean i lived
that
yeah i lived that tim it's one thing
it's one thing to study what they say
it's another thing to live in the late
90s and the early 2000s
i don't know let me tell you this in the
in the late 90s
i was only able to get like one power
ranger action figure but for some reason
now that i'm 34 i could buy all of them
the economy must be great it must be way
good
right now it seems like the economy is
falling apart right now with our
own yeah well it's not just that it's
covet
kobe it's killing it i'll tell you this
i'll tell you that's the death though
they just said they just had the cdc
director on i'm pretty sure
he was saying we never said the lock
down shut down schools
we never said to do this and new york's
like i'm gonna do it anyway it's like
whoa whoa whoa whoa
why did i why why is new york shutting
down the schools when the cdc's never
recommended that
because then the parents can't go to
work so why would they do this
[ __ ] the economy yeah it's crippling
the economy i'm not gonna say they're
doing it on purpose but
man these people they must know what
they're doing destroying the economy
they want they want they want um they
want bigger rent
they want you to know why you need them
well check this out if we remove the
little guy
you know his little mom and pop shop and
all of that and we make this
amazon monopoly come about who will
spend money and doesn't care if they
lose money
yeah that's crazy right then i can
charge them a premium and rent
and then you know real estate goes up in
this area and all of these people are
invested in real estate and invested in
these companies and so are these you
know
you know you know the amazon store in
seattle the one where you okay
so you sign up when you walk in the
cameras scan you yeah take whatever you
want and you walk out and it charges you
right
right so i did this bit where i went and
figured out how to actually walk out
without getting charged for any goods
very easily how did you do that so uh
i already released information before
and i'll tell you this
when people learn how a magic trick is
done it loses the magic
yes but it really is very simple so i i
when i saw that they they launched this
store i'll tell you the first part the
first point i want to make
when i discovered how to easily steal
whatever i want without being tracked
i called and asked for a comment and the
response i got was basically
we don't care about shoplifting because
we make so much money
that if some you could steal everything
and we still make more money yes
they were like by not hiring anybody
we're making ridiculous profits
stealing means nothing to us yeah and
and shortages accounted for anyway
exactly so they put in the price and so
they're like we don't care that you
figure this out and i was like shrinkage
i'm sorry
it was so easy to do anybody could do it
right now and they're like we literally
don't care
yeah so here's how you do it it's really
simple you just have someone else fill
up a bag
and then you pick the bag up and walk
out and it doesn't charge you
because they're tracking the bag not
what's in it so if someone fills a bag
up and then you pick it up and walk out
with it
and then the person walks out with no
bag no one gets charged oh that's
amazing
yeah so don't do that by the way hey you
know my people out there trying to get
reparations
no no no don't do that but the point was
they told me they were they were like
the funny thing was they kind of freaked
out when they found out i did it because
i filmed a video on it yeah and i showed
like my app said
nothing was was charged and i made sure
something got charged on purpose so you
could see that i had a receipt it was a
pack of gum right and i was like but you
can clearly see we got a bunch of stuff
but we did pay for it i didn't steal
anything right what we did was we just
swapped bags to see if it would work
okay and so they basically were like
wait a minute
did you swap bags with someone and i was
like yes and they were like
oh and i was like but you realize that
allows people to walk out like oh of
course but
you know we don't care exactly we make
so much money we just don't like that
and that's and that's and that's exactly
who they want to replace new york real
estate with yeah
people who got money to burn and then
you know what's crazy
i was talking to my friend about kogit
lockdown and he said we need a lockdown
we need to lock down now hard and the
government needs to just pay everybody
to stay home
and i said where do you think that money
comes from and he goes the taxpayer
and i was like even if that was the case
do you know where the money is going
it's going to big
box stores it's going to amazon yeah it
is the largest
wealth transfer ever in history if all
they did was print money
then they're diluting your your money
and your savings taking your job away so
you can't make money then giving it all
to the ultra wealthy major monopolies
yeah if it was just taxpayer dollars he
was like no it's taxpayer dollars
they're giving it back to the people
and then the people give it right back
to amazon because mom and pop shops are
closed
yeah so you're transferring your wealth
to amazon they don't care about losing
money they got too much
and they're going to buy up these
buildings and they're going to replace
all these stores and it's going to be
owned by a small handful of people
poor people make poor decisions i think
so i think i think
uh it's it's it's broad but it is
generally true
but the way i put it is a person is
smart people are stupid
uh who a person is smart people people
are stupid
to quote it's from men in black yeah a
person is smart people are dumb panicky
animals
yeah especially when you put them
together in packs yeah they tend to
infect each other with the same
ignorance yeah so he wants a lockdown
that's that's my big problem with the
lockdown the lockdowns it's like
a lot of governments aren't even saying
like i saw like two
black people blue checks like oh we need
another lot man i'm like
for what if you are afraid of the covet
virus
don't come outside lock yourself down
quarantine yourself
i'll tell you this man this is the
libertarian versus authoritarian i'm not
saying everybody who wants a lockdown is
a hardcore authoritarian they might just
not be very smart or it might be the one
issue but
i remember when they banned cigarettes
in chicago from bars and i didn't
understand it
they were like they're gonna pass a
city-wide ordinance you can't smoke in
restaurants or bars anymore and i was
like i don't understand why
why why are they doing that yeah cause
because i don't smoke i hate smoking
because it's effective somebody else's
health sure sure but
i i've i tried smoking when i was a kid
everyone's like here try a sega i try a
cigarette don't like it i don't want to
smoke don't smoke i don't smoke weed i
don't i used to drink i don't drink
right i don't tell people they can't do
it and so if i go to an establishment
and they say you want to smoke and
people are smoking and i don't like it
you know what i do i just leave i leave
right it's really simple yeah it's not
very hard i just get to walk out yeah
yeah so i i totally agree with that you
know i like i like
i like bolton's you know because
sometimes you're at a family restaurant
and it's like oh yeah i got a smoking
section and it's just like
maybe restaurants should have been the
ones to dictate that
right but um i think if they lose the
business because families don't want to
go there go
yeah exactly somebody should and that's
that's why i say like
that ruins capitalism right yeah you
come in you set this ordinance that says
hey
you know smoking's bad for everybody
when you could have just waited for some
capital and say hey look
we don't allow smoking in our building
everybody come here and then all the
non-smokers will go there and then
smokers will go here and everybody's
happy you know i think what happened is
they would slowly start
making the smoking areas small smaller
and further away but
i guess you know the difference between
smokers and non-smokers is what is it
smokers tip better really they tip
better oh yeah
really smokers used to tip better bro
really why is that
uh because they're cooler people oh yeah
that explains it yeah i mean
these are these are people that are cool
down the earth they kind of you smoke
i used to oh okay i smoke weed every now
and then um
i'll have a cigarette every now and then
if i'm having alcohol like you know
whatever whatever but i'm not a smoker i
used to be a smoker
but nah man you know uh you know
non-smokers tend to be like
you know real snooty and you know is
that that white is that how i got you
smoke right
i'm uptight and snooty and arrogant yeah
me too how dare you sir come into my
home with your cigarettes yeah
so we got that puritan movement that was
in you know heavy in the united states
and in some ways i agree in some ways i
don't and i agree in a lot of ways
culturally
but when they start like legislating
stuff i'm like ah that's where i'm
partnering with you man
it's it's you know there's it's it's not
just uh one way or the other it's not
it's not black or white
there's nuance some things that make
sense to say you can't do like
as best as maybe you know what i mean
right because people aren't
aren't realizing that's around them yeah
and then all sudden you get some
something happens people get sick
there's also the issue when it comes to
smoking i can understand the point i
don't necessarily agree with it that
people don't realize how much damage
they're doing by having these
establishments where people smoke yeah
for instance you might not mind smoking
right you might not mind the smoke from
other people right but it's messing you
up a little bit yes
so you go into the bar and you're like i
don't care doesn't bother me but now
it's creating a net negative for the you
know for everybody else
indeed but the problem i have with that
is the logical conclusion is to just
take everything
take anything pleasurable just you know
lock people down and that that's to me
that's just
it's ridiculous you look you remember
what bloomberg did when he banned soda
large sodas what what do you do michael
bloomberg in new york banned large soda
right i'm pretty sure he did
i don't know if he's yeah i remember
yeah yeah and then unity said when he
was asked about it
taxed the poor he said the poor make
poor people make poor decisions
he basically said that he said you've
got all these poor people that waste
their money on things that are bad for
their health
and if we were managing their lives for
them they'd be better off
yeah yeah uh-uh i mean the government
the government just
just they suck at holding you know
some people accountable which is why
they shouldn't be allowed to make these
decisions because if it was me i would
just ban soda period like look don't
sell no
don't sell no still sold on my steak
done they're sure you would ban
soda i'd ban soda i mean if i was an
evil dictator
right right oh i'd ban cilantro oh yeah
for sure
i'm kidding i just don't like it sugars
i don't
i don't like fennel anise caraway and
cilantro get it out just get rid of it
yeah i know i i go back and forth with
you know the the existence of this state
i'm like
i don't like the existence of the state
but if i'm dictator you'll yeah
so yeah right so hold on here's the
here's always a big challenge right
do you think china is doing their best
to to dominate to take over to seize
power and land and resources
oh they're doing such a great job so
what would happen if we didn't have the
state
they just walk right in what do you mean
walk right in they already took over
they
walked right in well joe biden's pres
president-elect they said so
you know i guess so they own our debt
they trade our debt
they own land they don't eat large
swaths of land in the western u.s
chinese military on every corner you
can't even buy something that's not from
china
like what do you mean like well well i
got this uh aren't my pillows from
america they are from america yeah yeah
i got one of those things
mike yeah you know my pillow yeah pillow
guys part what part of it is from
america and what part of it is
wait he's got the uh the giza sheets
from from from egypt
oh okay no i'm pretty sure they make the
whole thing in america
nice to see you here as well yeah yeah
props to stuff like that right so if
people
really cared like those industries would
thrive
people say look let's start with pillows
right the great pillow revolution
and then everybody just slowly transfer
that right i think we need to start with
shoes
if you want if you want to screw over
china start with shoes yep
discovered plastic and graphene you
wanna you want something yeah i like
that too yeah you wanna hear something
crazy
who's that you wanna know how they make
skateboards oh the wood comes from
typically canada okay they send it to
china
they cut it and turn it to a skateboard
and ship it to california
amazing what is china doing that we
can't do
i'm gonna tell you what listen listen
what this is what's crazy yeah it is
cheaper because of the labor costs yes
to get the wood from canada
ship it thousands of miles to china yeah
then thousands of miles back
because people in america for labor cost
too much money
no because we have something called
minimum wage yeah
but that's the problem and china doesn't
have no minimum wage they're going to
pay you whatever the heck
to get it done and i like that no no i
think you know what it might be but it
might be free trade
how so so if we just said
if a skateboard is being imported and it
costs it
is undercutting american goods we put a
tariff on it yeah that's one way to do
it
you know but again that's like utilizing
the government i just say
you know um repeal
these laws like repeal minimum wage and
then that becomes a school project what
if kids in schools for school projects
made skateboards and every kid that
wanted to make skateboards
spent an hour making skateboards a day
all across the nation it's pretty fun
right like what if that was a job for
skateboarders like yo bro you want to
really rad
work for a day in in in you know like
there's ways that these things can
happen
and besides machines are going to do it
so you really just feed it into a
machine and
the machine skateboards work i don't
know if i don't know if they do it that
way
is there some hand hand tooling yeah
so you you put it's the seven layers of
wood and then they have a mold and they
put the glue on it and then they press
it and they hold it down for a certain
amount of time okay i i
they probably have some kind of mass
production process for sure especially
in china
yeah you know you know the big problem
is though is that
very obviously and uh with all due
respect the boards that come out of
china are not good
no kidding i could i could imagine
they're just trying to meet me to quota
and shop and ship them out as i said you
got to have people who like actually
care about it if a skateboarder made the
skateboard everyone would come out
perfect
you know but the big companies that know
how to do it
get the labor and everything done in
china those are really really those are
the best
okay so when the wood comes from u.s or
canadian rock maple and gets sent over
and then press and everything is sent
back and then they quality test it and
they know so when does the when is the
tim pool skateboarding
manufacturing company company actually
yeah we're going to do it we're totally
doing it that's dope
so we got uh the detached building
outside they're turning it into a skate
park
okay and then we've got a back room and
i'm just gonna i'm gonna
start making a bunch of gear yeah we'll
have some beanies we'll have some shirts
we'll have some skateboards
and we're gonna film videos save america
one skateboard at a time that's correct
made in america so
here's a challenge though dude
everything's made in china
right so i've i've looked at some
american companies and they're like i'm
like they're not that good
because if they're expensive for one i
don't mind that
but that means people buy it from me i'm
not looking to make a hard profit off of
the goods yeah i'll probably sell them
at cost to cover costs because we're
going to be doing videos and we're going
to be doing youtube and so we'll
probably try and find ways to monetize
in other directions
but it's still going to be expensive
compared to these boards they send over
to china because the labor is so cheap
man goes to chinese man he said chinese
man
you're getting this materials from
another chinese man
for a double the price you're getting it
that i'm offering
chinese man go yeah but i buy from
chinese man
yup you see that he's he'll he'll he'll
pay double
to keep the money in the fam to keep the
power of the power of the chain
uh supply chain before he
allows you to infiltrate the industry
that's in america culture
that's what americans don't got they
don't got that culture where they say
i'll do without
unless one of my own makes it it's that
independent spirit
yeah and stop asking trump to do it
trump got enough swamp creatures around
him to worry about help him
yeah you think he's going to win no
i want him to i mean you know we got a
old girl with the kraken what's her name
cindy powell yeah you know allegedly she
got the crack and it's like let that
thing out you know we only got like
two three i i mean i mean she had it she
would have released the joint right
maybe not uh the the argument is that
she's got to wait to present to a judge
right and i think it's a fair point if
she started going into the media and
dumping all these documents yeah they
get mad well that too and then people
could tear it apart and start to plan
for it i know they're gonna have to have
some time for discovery don't give your
enemies
your strategy so i get it there's a lot
of things that we don't understand about
the legal system that has to take place
so i'm putting my trust in cindy powell
and giuliani
and hoping that they know what they're
doing right and and uh
i think there's a chance that they might
be able to bring something before the
supreme court and keep president trump
and i think that there there is a play
to be had there because
the media's going to take a ton of money
they're going to win big off of
trump because people will be mad for
another four years you know what's that
how much that's worth the equity in that
so
i'd love to see it i'd love to see the
left crying and tears again
you remember 2016. yes you were you said
you were laughing
yeah i was having a good time right we
saw this like
throughout the night there was a
slow-motion breakdown where yeah the new
york times had that meter and it was
like 99
hillary clinton yeah and throughout the
night it slowly started moving over yeah
and you could see
with each passing moment the meter
moving the sweat was getting thicker and
thicker and like
the freak out and then once it crossed
over to 50 50 it's like shaking
yeah i was in a room with i was was
hanging out cassandra fairbanks
and she was all for trump but she was
like i know he's not going to win
and everyone else this office were like
snooty democrat pro hillary
throughout the night she started smiling
and laughing
everyone else was freaking out crying
once once they called it for trump i
just
was laughing like hilarious yeah but i
tell you this man
if trump pulls it off whatever their
plan is maybe there's a kraken i don't
know
i think i think chances are slim like
you said you don't think he's gonna win
but we'll see
but i'll tell you this i hope he does
though they went out dancing in the
street this time
who was a million megamarch no no no all
the democrats when they went oh
yeah when this happened yeah they're
popping champagne they're pulling their
masks off
sharing bottles yeah could you imagine a
month-long slow-motion defeat
compared to a one-day slow motion defeat
i'm hoping that's what happened
it's gonna instead of instead of just a
uh like a half an hour of them get like
nervously shaking
it's gonna be a week of them like
freaking out if we get to that point
yeah yeah
but the other side of me says if if
biden
is true and indeed the the president
then we get to see the disappearance of
black lives matter and i'd love to see
them disappear
right black people we go back to the
back of the bus
and and and i like it better there where
you know white people leave us alone and
stop trying to use us for their agendas
because if biden's president you can no
longer say there's a police brutality
problem because that would mean you
voted them in
that's true that's the difference so
this stuff started under obama
yeah and then but well it didn't start
under obama
right right right yes well black lives
matter officially formalized but
correct the things that were happening
happening for a while right but now the
big difference with biden is that
they voted him in right so you can't
complain now you had you had back during
uh
uh ferguson and stuff like i didn't vote
for obama the second time i voted him
for the first time
okay then immediately regretted it right
because he started the war and i'll
start doing more war stuff
yeah but i knew a lot of people who were
like i didn't vote i didn't vote for him
i don't care you know they were young
they were 18
it was 2012 2013 so they didn't vote for
him the first or second time
yeah now they did now they did vote for
biden right so now it's like
when all this stuff keeps happening you
got nobody to blame yourself and what's
going to happen is somebody's going to
capture
some police brutality on film they're
going to record it it's going to go
viral on twitter or something else
and they're going to ask themselves why
isn't msnbc
covering this why isn't cnn and it's
like well do you remember that under
obama's presidency
when black lives matter first hit the
scene and it was a hashtag they wouldn't
let the hashtag trend and they gave it
unfavorable coverage
those are the times we're gonna go back
to and i like those times when they
ignore black people because that's when
we really start coming together
it works really well for us when the
white liberals are not business
it just sends us awry this is this is
what i can't stand
uh about the modern left though i grew
up on the south side of chicago
we had people of all different races and
backgrounds never really came up
like right yeah yeah it was it was like
we had
i always tell the story we had one
friend who would call everybody by their
racial slur but we thought it was funny
yeah because we grew up watching south
park and family guy so it was like oh
it's very toxic culture
you think so well according to left
standards oh right right right but
having a friend walk up and be like you
know he's like yo what up and then
you know spot like a slur i'd be like
well what up dude like
what's going on it was like we were all
hanging out it was never an issue to
anybody
yeah those are the great 90s early 2000s
and then
i went to occupy wall street and all of
a sudden they were like we got to put
all the different races in different
groups no joke
they had they had voting occupy wall
street new york
cicada park yeah you know dwayne henry
uh i'm pretty sure
he had to he ran media they had a long
time that's my homie right on
yeah yeah well they they created
caucuses where they put different races
in different voting groups
really i'm not a fan of that now wow i
didn't know that i used to pop up there
every once in a while give a few
speeches
you know ruffle a few feathers and argue
with people did you have the same
hair because it was super short though
right on it was just growing in
yeah that's young daddy boston i was
young jesus
i was hanging out there i'd sleep in the
park like really yeah
okay yeah totally it was a good time it
was fun but but think about the premises
a lot of crazy people though what was
the premise of that
initially i mean it was initially it's
the same problem now they're blind
they're blaming trump for all the woes
whereas
our we're printing up trillions and
trillions of dollars but you see how
you see how the original movement was
centered around the big problem the real
problem
it should be too and then all of a
sudden it shifted to
all these other problems i went to this
million magum march and i was talking to
people
on the street about the federal reserve
and everybody would light up when i
would start talking about it
have you seen this comic where there is
this like it's like a very fancy looking
room okay and there's a guy sitting at a
desk with like a big fancy chair there's
a big window
outside the window it's a bunch of
protesters and a big sign says occupy
wall street being held up
and the man sitting at the table smiling
and he says introduce identity politics
yeah that's that's really what happened
yeah the the people
i'm like man the revolution will not be
televised your revolution that you're
following is is controlled it's
controlled opposition
and and they saw that they saw quickly
with the occupy movement they said oh no
we can't have this we got to start
controlling the opposition
and then that's what they did with
antifa black lives matter and some of
these other organizations
early on at occupy like the first week
there were conservatives and
libertarians down there hanging out with
these
like socialist anarchists really there
was a there was a uh
but here's here's what happens two
things
you you get these brooklyn progressives
trust fund kids
okay a small handful of them yes they're
real they're exist i know them
and we like i was friends with them they
didn't have to work
so they had apartments they're really
well off and they would come in the
morning
and then organize so this ideology
became much more pervasive because
they could be there and have to work but
the older people who showed up early on
and many of the more libertarian people
they worked
right so what happens is you take these
rich progressives
college students who have nothing
nothing else to do right they're there
all day
setting things up organizing and then
the other people are going to work
coming back going to work
eventually the whole place got dominated
by just leftist ideology
and then the older people after a week
were like well i gotta go back to work
so they leave
and there were even people who weren't
necessarily older maybe like you know
people who were in their 30s at the
times
10 years ago now almost 10 years ago and
they'd be like i can only be out here
for about a week i gotta go back to my
job yeah that was me
yup i was wondering i'm like yo how are
these people sitting here like don't
they got jobs and lives
like how are they doing this the people
who did eventually had to move on
wow and then the people who didn't
started coming and hanging out and it
became dominated by a specific ideology
so
the leftists took that over too yeah and
the crazy thing about it is
is that uh people the history of occupy
wall street
is all fake news like because it was
written by
it was written by those who wanted it to
be romanticized the whole time
right right they won't tell you about
how they were stealing money they won't
tell you about the organizers who
started getting
800 a night hotel rooms oh they won't
tell you about the organizers who
took a you know a laptop was donated for
the community and then one of the
organizers like well i need it more than
they do
yeah they don't tell you about that
stuff they don't tell you about how the
park got divided into two different
groups the general assembly and the
general union
and the general union said that the
resources and donations were being
stolen by these trust fund brooklyn kids
who don't even sleep here there was one
night where the general union which was
this was the
west side of the park raided the kitchen
they went to the kitchen and said the
people who sleep here in the park for
your protest yeah
they need water and the people who work
the kitchen who didn't sleep there
said we don't have any so they jumped
over the table
and flipped some stuff over and found
bottles of water and picked them up
carried them out and started handing
them out to people
these are the stories that most people
didn't hear so which side
was you backing neither oh which one
well in that particular situation who do
you think was in the right the
union that's the people that stole the
water bottles yep absolutely but if
they're handing them out to people who
are
rich kids no they were handing them out
to the people who are sleeping in the
park
but you said the people sleeping in a
park with the rich kids no no no the
people who were rich
would go back to their homes in brooklyn
where they had apartments
and first thing in the morning show back
up clean you know
ready to go ready to go and presentable
to organize collect donations go on tv
and the people sleeping in the park were
getting filthy and stinky and gross yeah
and so those people start getting mad
like dude we're the ones who are making
this occupy
happen right and you're the one
exploiting it and guess who got to go on
tv and
and and do all this you know preaching
and stuff it was the kids who had
apartments i got to
i'm not saying that all of them were
rich some of them were some of them were
like just
as rich as they come some of them were
just you know they had apartments in
brooklyn
and so that already put them an
advantage over some of these other
people so so so who do we blame
that on nobody what's the cause of that
why does why do things like that happen
when you have something good why do why
do things like that happen
i think this was an issue of uh power
over time
the people who had a state of human
consciousness
yeah it's a state of the state of human
consciousness if you
she mentioned before human evolution the
human has not evolved
the human has devolved we're going
backwards in evolution and technology is
helping us do that
we are not civilized there's nothing
civilized about the united states
when they came over here and stole land
from the natives that wasn't civilized
to kill people isn't civilized
isn't it different today though no like
nothing
civilized about about garbage
being on the street in new york city and
it's stinking how is that civilized no
that i would agree with
there's nothing civilized about america
yes but i think that violence is the
default state of the human being
i think that violence is what we come
from and the fact that we have any kind
of peace at all
is a form of evolution well my answers
would say
violence is the default state for the
white man
that's my default state for everyone
they would say the white man
that's yeah because y'all the only ones
that say that [ __ ]
really don't look it don't don't look at
me i come from a mixed race
of all these accusations you guys you
guys telling yourselves y'all admit it
you say the default state of humans is
violence this is just something and the
hoteps
say no that's not the default well lydia
did just say it but that's the leftists
for the most part
this like critical race theory you know
whiteness stuff
i think most conservatives wouldn't say
that that's i don't know what
conservatives would say but i hear that
a lot from white people
because you know you know what's
interesting you brought up ian having no
faith in people
i think it's interesting when
conservatives are the ones advocating
for everybody have guns
because they they're not worried about
if someone else has a gun right that's
interesting yeah because they believe in
people more
that's interesting they actually believe
in people conservatives believe in
people liberals do not believe in people
which is why they try to legislate
that's why i'm saying
this that's why i'm saying like the the
you know the white people being the
violent one that's that's the leftist
critical race theory stuff
yeah but she's not leftist and she said
how did that get in her brain yeah i
don't know well i read a book about it
because i
who wrote the book if you go through if
you go through history though you read
about the aztecs you can read about the
mayans you read about the japanese you
read about what
united throws the st
off people yeah it fell off i mean dude
dude shot because chaka zulu was legit a
warlord
i mean zulu you talking about that's
post-colonial
colonial ever you know they when you got
the colonists coming in and turning the
zulu tribe into 13 different tribes
that's that's resistance to white power
what about what about genghis khan
genghis khan is a white man no we're not
clean we're not claiming
genghis khan is good i'm trolling i'm
trolling um
for you before we go okay move on from
this i really want to know have you been
to africa
yes really yes what part did you go to
tanzania dar salon
interesting so what what did you see
there did you feel like they were really
really well evolved did you find a great
deal of peace there
yeah you could yeah it's one of the most
peaceful places
the most violence you'll have is maybe
knife violence but you know you're
pretty much safe in dar salaam tanzania
there's tons of poverty
but the culture there here's the
difference
the people there can live off the land
until they legislate against it
right yeah so if i'm hungry i could go
climb this tree and have a mango or i
can go and fish the sea
there's no communist dictator that's
gonna tell me hey there's no fishing
allowed
i watch the people with my own two eyes
live off the land
catch crab and catch fish and catch
coconuts so it's really interesting that
you bring that up because this is
something that thomas so well talks
about
he talks about the reason that people
who lived in the north people who ended
up being white scandinavians
yeah having this sense of preparation
and needing to sacrifice for the future
because if they didn't they die in the
winter
correct whereas in the african around
the equator you're warm you could just
drop it by the side of the road it would
grow two weeks later and you'd be good
to go
and he said that this affected our
culture very deeply yes but thomas soul
is my strongest influencer well hold on
hold on it makes me think
what about what about east asia i don't
know i get we see
you see you know here's the thing right
i was i was hanging out in
north dakota talking to some of these
leftists at the north dakota access
pipeline protest
and this guy started telling me long
story short i said i've got to make it
to la for a meeting
and the guy said that's colonial
thinking and i was like what do you mean
he was like this idea of schedules like
the native americans they don't have
this man you know they wake up when they
got to wake up they work when they go to
work but like you the schedule
that's that's colonial thinking and then
when i was like
he said time and scheduling our colonial
i said what are you talking about like
the east asia developed a whole bunch of
stuff well before like white europeans
calendars the the the founders the
compass was a thousand years
before uh in china before europe and
this dude said
yeah but you know europeans went to
china and i'm like you know what man
and i mean i mean it's half jokingly you
guys are talking about africa or like
northern europe i'm like what about asia
huh yeah like we had warlords
yeah they they brutally raped and
murdered people like well yeah
what is it your five percent japanese
was an accident dude
oh yeah right so uh yeah i'm i'm i'm uh
par i'm mostly korean but part japanese
because you know japan was like
brutal yeah taken taking the women you
know what i mean
but i mean we have to question our own
psyche before we even pontificate upon
history and the records that we read
we got to check ourselves we can't just
say that
because i've read in a book that human
consciousness begins at
violence you can't accept that you can't
accept that yeah
just simply for the pure health of the
race the human race
i don't think that it's good i think our
current situation is better which was
what makes me think that we have evolved
our current situation is better relative
to the time
right right i don't i don't i would
disagree in some ways and i would agree
in some ways
right it's better because you're living
in it right right and what you read
about the old times
seems like it's all bad and and i'm like
i don't know i
i take a time machine back i might be
all right
i got my girlfriend that nobody wants
because i live in the middle of nowhere
whereas today i might have to compete
with 20 other dudes on instagram who got
money and his dm in her
yeah life was simpler back then right
you know you know what's crazy about i'm
watching these movies like period pieces
from like you know the 16
1700s yeah is that nothing happened
okay relative to today where every day
there's something crazy going on right
back then you'd wake up tend to the
chickens yeah you know
till the field or whatever go but you
know go about your work and then it was
like once a month when the post writer
came by and you're like wow that
happened three months ago huh
that's crazy right it was court drama
back then and the king's court is where
all the drugs what do you think that
does for human consciousness
aren't you zenned out what do people do
now when they want to get zenned out
they go to colorado and they hit the
mountains or
right burning man i guess yeah that's
not get away from the technology right
they have these things called retreats
and technology retreats
and you get away from the technology and
what do people always say like
i'm so much different when i come back
and then when i've used social media it
looks so much different
okay so your consciousness changed so
what's really altering our consciousness
is the
millions of thoughts that get dumped
into our mind by this device that tells
us
you know humans are naturally violent
you ever tried dmt humans
oh my gosh you can't hit me with the joe
roger question
yeah we got that comic from george
i have not i don't do i'm black i don't
do white people drugs
maybe maybe that's why i did it because
we're part asian in me
i can't i can't say i won't do it but my
mind is so out there i'm scared to do it
even further out yeah yeah and i had a
friend who who
i watched um who was a sane individual
he did some sort of
uh psychedelic drug and it reverted him
into a 10 year old so now i'm kind of
like
i've i had stories growing up about
people who had bad trips and never came
never came back
yeah yeah that's why i've just been like
and the way i'm like
in my head now i'm like i don't need to
get that much further because i
i'm in my head man you know like i have
35 different personalities and we have
great conversations together that sounds
great
you know and i think i want to stay
there the most i'll do is add a role
adderall is a great drug i i think
everybody should try
i think all drugs are bad to focus i'm
not a fan of any of them you think all
drugs are bad
for them i like that most part that's
cool i understand that they're that like
when we're talking about drugs that
might actually cure diseases
that's different but have you ever had
adorable before yeah yeah you didn't
like it
didn't really do anything what'd you do
what'd you do when you got it
just sat there and walked around that's
the problem
that role is not for just sitting and
walking around adderall is for
getting [ __ ] done i i know people who
have problems and it's like these things
didn't help them i know people who have
been prescribed medications it doesn't
help them
it doesn't yeah i think i think people
need to strengthen their willpower they
need to strengthen their core
i'm not going to be as so blind as to
say that everybody like i i know people
who are on antidepressants because
there's nothing they can do like
depression is a medical issue yeah it's
a dependency
i i think their instances like i i've
heard all these stories where someone
someone will say something dumb like if
you're depressed just get over it it's
like dude people who are depressed can't
do that otherwise
we have better better solutions but i do
think for the most part
people need to exercise they need to eat
right they need to
be well-rounded they need to like have
some kind of meditation or some kind of
you need mental fortitude and you need
to strengthen yourself i i can't just
cure the cure for go ahead i actually i
actually really think that this ties
into what you were saying earlier which
is something that i was going to say
that i agree with you on
i'm a huge proponent of understanding
yourself yeah i don't think that you get
to understand the world until you
understand
yourself gotta understand you can think
about yourself for years on end not in a
selfish way but in a way that i want to
figure out what's going on with you i
know what i'm thinking i think this is
why jordan peterson took off
and i think that if he's turning people
away from drugs that's fantastic
so i think that really ties together you
are who you are when you buy yourself
exactly and i try to have the most pure
thoughts when i'm by myself that's why i
pick up on stuff when you guys say all
these pessimistic stuff i'm like
yeah why do you guys think that about
people like pissing on me like
that's not even a thought i would allow
to enter my mind you know like
i i practice like purification of of my
consciousness right
i would also argue that it's very
important to try to entertain other
people's ideas and see where they
entertain all of them that's that's a
major key to
yeah that's how we can have co-op
conversations like you heard when he
said you know like i was like oh i love
adderall and he was like
you know drugs are bad and i'm like i
agree right right like i love
that exchange because that's how you
sharpen this prism of my mind
right like i get to see the world
through your eyes i get to see the world
through his eyes
so next time i'm thinking about anarchy
i'm like what are we gonna do about
people that like pissing on people's
faces
no we ain't calling the cops no we're
dealing with it
we're going to call we're going to call
the hotep security team
my little friend hotep task force but
what if the other guy calls his task
force and then the other guy calls his
task force and then everybody
i got it mine is more badass we build a
culture around
instead of fighting to solve our
problems we just do some kind of you
know like sporting event like okay okay
everybody stop we gotta stop
soccer match we're gonna do it yeah
one day big bully guy i want to kick my
ass
you know what happened talk my way right
out of it there you go
it run away talk my way right out of it
nine people i've talked i've talked
people out of so many different
situations
it's it's understanding human psychology
is you know it's it does wonderful
what about like what about like hong
kong
um so one time i was uh with my home
girl
and uh my fiance and we were smooching
outside the car
some dude rolls up on us to rob us he's
like yo i just came from the gym i need
some money
i'm like oh bro how much you need she
was going she
hopped in the car lock all the doors so
i'm sitting outside with this dude who's
sweating got his wife beat her on
he's like y'all need some money i'm like
dude how much you need bro he's like yo
i need like 20 dollars right i'm like
that's it bro
like i looked around i found an atm i'm
like it was an atm right there i would
give you a ride over there let you have
in the car but you scared my lady
meet me by the atm i got you bro i hop
in the car
[Laughter]
gone it's about about knowing yeah it's
about
controlling your fear yeah identifying
emotions
thinking on your feet you got to have
that level of consciousness we have to
work on our consciousness so i keep
saying it man
and and and there's a lot of things you
can just avoid man i swear to god i talk
myself out of a gunfight man
yeah dude i believe you i do agree that
we are evolving that
hominids are not going to be sapient
forever that will develop some sort of
psychic connection or develop our
psychic connection
but a lot of people are with food
different high fructose
with aspartame with you know you know
conspiracy staring into a computer
screen
you know do you know about lemuria um
i've heard of lemur it's an ancient
civilization
yes atlantis
right these are the people that are
operating off of the intuition
these are people that are operating off
of high powers these are people that
didn't need cell phones because if i
want to talk to you i just look at you
and transmit the thoughts they got wiped
out by a comet so they didn't have the
tech
comet yeah the comet that shattered over
north america and melted the glaciers
they didn't have the tech to stop the
comet right
what if they detect to leave the earth
and we didn't know it that'd be awesome
and they did leave but i don't think
they did unfortunately how do you know
all signs pointed they got covered with
mud huh but how do you know the people
didn't leave
well there's just no evidence of it
there's no evidence that they didn't
leave there's evidence that
covered by mud atlanta that the city of
the sahara yeah where are the bodies
under the mud man i don't know uh
exactly so you have no bodies
all right all right hold on they went to
the how much how much will it cost to to
fund an expedition to go and start doing
a dig at the top
70 million dollars how much would it
cost to stop the next comment from
wiping us out
man it's good a lot of energy a lot of
focus
you think do you think we can do it yeah
heck yeah yeah
he's i love him he's optimistic about
the wildest stuff he is
these little problems that we got like
people pissing on you oh that's too
impossible without government when we
come back to humans or wild animals that
we tame we basically tamed our bodies
why are we wild
how do you we're just monkeys evolved
monkeys and then we're that's another
white thought
that's another white people i think
monkeys ate a bunch of mushrooms and
evolved over time and inbred and evolved
into what we are
that's the european we seem to be i mean
we're very similar to monkeys and apes
and stuff
but we have these more animals we're
more similar to plants but
why do you think plants why is that i
ain't going to go into it because i
don't know all the science to be saying
that [ __ ] but if you go look it up
are we more similar to apes or plants
and need to tell you a lot about the
similarities between the human body and
plants
we may not have evolved i haven't
studied that stuff in years but it seems
like well
we look very similar to apes so we have
this we're we're animals we're straight
up animals
and we have this wildness to us
especially when we get hungry and
desperate
so i'm just accepting that trying to
figure things out like yeah a guy will
pee on you if he has to and he's angry
if he has to yeah i have no choice i'm
sorry i mean when you when you starve
people yeah
right but even if you go based upon you
know creation theory like god put us in
the garden of even
eating and you know we had food right so
i think the herbs is here for us we you
know we don't even eat from the earth we
eat synthetic foods
i think that story was written by like
people well regardless regardless of
what you think of the story
regardless what you think of the story i
don't believe in the story either but
my point is why aren't we living off
plans
i mean we got a bunch of vegan pizzas
that's fine i think that's cool my point
is this
we got to stop saying we're animals
because of the dogma that comes
with that it removes all responsibility
of higher consciousness
so would you say so we just act like
monkeys we're not monkeys if we were
monkeys why are the monkeys still here
you are well i mean you're
you say what you're not a religious
person so where are you coming from
i'm not a religious person where am i
coming from yeah yeah so well
you're talking about how people are
they're not evolved from monkeys there's
something better
something different to me that sounds
like a lot like christianity which is
where i was raised
this is the way you were raised i hold i
hold a lot of different theories right
so i hold the theory that
we're we're actually an ancient race
that was created
using monkey dna anunnaki kamiros you
know
yeah yeah so i'll hold that theory i'll
hold the creation theory
the evolution thing kind of sidesteps me
that doesn't that doesn't really hold
truth with me
you know um
i'm not gonna say that but yeah i i i
don't believe
we are humans i believe i mean i don't
believe we are animals
um i believe that we are in many ways
guardians and you said religious rights
i don't practice
you know a specific religion i borrow
from all of them but i'm very religious
like i religiously pray before i eat i
religiously pray
you know throughout the day you know
muslims pray five times a day i try to
pray
like 10 you know or when i'm conscious
of it or you know even in a moment
or for example like when kanye was on
joe rogan he
took a minute to pray when i see things
happen in the media i take a moment to
pray
so i'm very religious in that sense i'm
you know the
i don't believe in the abrahamic
religions because i know all of that
stuff comes from the non-valley
civilization
but i still appreciate the stories
you know i appreciate the buddha theory
i don't i don't jive for buddhism
because i feel like
we shouldn't sidestep the human body
right the human body is very important
but i think there's a lot of
spirituality missing from these
religions
from people from from
from the translations of the books you
know
like the things that jesus was pulling
off he wasn't pulling it off because he
was special
he was pulling it off because he learned
it he studied what he studied
he studied for 12 years i heard that he
went to india and studied reiki
and hinduism came back with that healing
energy
you should do reiki manufacturing reiki
is a fix
electromagnetic field surrounding your
body you can divert and maneuver the
energy
yes called aura yeah you move your aura
you can like put it into people and
withdraw it from them
intermingle it with other auras
yeah i mean again i just don't deal with
all these like different
sex and titles you know like oh this is
reiki and this is that
the the bottom line is everything is
energy
right and we have this energetic field
around us
but the earth is is basically dominated
by two forces
electric electricity and magnetism
electromagnet
magnetism one operates in space when it
operates
um in matter right so the magnetism of
things there's
a lot to be said about that um for
example like when we get into emoto
master rule and he talks about
what sound can do to water and and sound
technology so on so forth so then you
start
talking and saying things and i'm just
like don't say that
don't bring that thing into existence
don't say that we're animals don't say
you know that we're violent say
something positive and
and you know we create this reality
through our words right
so we got to start saying stuff like
donald trump will find a way to win
yeah i'm kidding by the way absolutely
right about positive manifestation
because people's minds don't understand
double negative
so if you say don't get angry you're
putting the word angry out there correct
and they're going to hear angry angry
angry i'll say it sounds like what ian's
also i've just accepted a sense of
realism about
things i don't know maybe i can go back
into the positive manifestation path i
did it for like six years it kind of
i got really like alienated from people
right because
it's it was harder to relate so you know
but
i just think there's a lot to be done as
far as telepathy is concerned
a lot to be done as far as intuition is
concerned
do you believe do you believe telepathy
is possible um
just say no no i i wouldn't say no say
no temple
i need i need evidence extraordinary
claims extraordinary evidence right you
need evidence
so i'm open to it so that that is that
is
logical yeah i said the same thing i
need evidence
so i started doing it and i gave myself
the evidence
or we get an oral link elon musk comes
in plugs everybody in and we can all
talk through our brains
no that's terrible idea right so that's
what i said terrible idea you know so i
did this experiment
with my kids right and we pull out three
uno cards
and they got numbers on them they got
colors on them and what we do is a
telepathy game
and what i found is that the you know i
have one son
who looks like his mother then the other
two are brown and they all look like me
so it's three of us
versus the other two when we checked it
out
the three browns against the light skins
they communicated very well between the
mother
they were able to guess one time
my daughter and her little brother were
doing it
and she said i heard it she heard
him scream in her mind telepathically
now you're going to tell her there's no
evidence when she heard the voice that's
her
i think it's real personally i've
experienced i'll tell you a story i know
this guy
who's a religious he's a christian and
uh
i asked him you know how did you become
christian and i've heard the story
before too from other people but he said
that he used to be just like this like
gutter punk
drug addict he would go and party one
day he was coming down from doing a
bunch of drugs and partying all night
woke up in the morning in the middle of
like he's like near like in the middle
of the woods with his friends
and he went out to go take a leak when
all of a sudden he heard this voice come
from within him
telling him that he like what are you
asking him what are you doing with your
life why are you doing this
you got to do something else and he said
like that freaked him out
he got immediately got like a panic
attack was like stressed like what's
happening
and the voice basically told him knock
it off stop and then
from then you know he tried to figure
out what that voice was and he believes
that it was either
you know guardian angel of some sort or
god i don't i don't i
would say it was his intuition we all
have a voice inside our head that told
us not to do something we did it anyway
we're like
i should have listened but the point was
that never happened to you temple
where something told you not to do
something did it anyway yeah so what was
that voice temple
was that that inner monologue yes that's
me that's you
what part of you how did it know the
future but you didn't listen because it
was you
said not to and then another you did it
anyway
so which one is you tim they're both
they're both you yeah so which one
is the better one well one of them said
we should
which one has higher intelligence temple
the one that was able to predict the
future the one that was wrong and went
and did that thing anyway
well i don't think it was i don't think
that's two different entities i think
it's just me
and the first thing i thought was i
shouldn't do this and i'll do it anyway
and then oops
see this is this is the problem that
religious people have with people like
you
right you guys don't know how to submit
to a higher power you think
all the power lies within you and that's
where the power starts to corrupt and we
end up pissing on people's heads
we were just talking about the elf the
uh extremely low frequency
vibration in the schumann resonance okay
earth's magnetosphere
okay it's uh a resonating
you know calculatable vibration that
changes it and sometimes you get these
spikes in the schumann resonance when
consciousness
human consciousness is like working in
coercion people are thinking about
something yeah
and sometimes i think that those those
intuitive thoughts that come are
actually coming from the earth's
yes magneto's like it's a connected
sphere yes we're all connected
we are all one we i am you you am i
it's super chat time it is absolutely
super chat it's well passing because
it's all yeah we went late on this one
yeah
oh definitely dude yeah we got we i've
been i've been saving this
i've been saving this one super chat i
saw just just so we're gonna get started
scott harris says i never donate to
anything because i'm broke and
i'm a broke bike messenger but this
episode is amazing hotep isn't just woke
he's up and out of bed that's right
i like that yeah that's good let's go
out of bed
all right let's see what we got let's
see
a lot of people just saying uh cheering
for you a lot of super chats
thank you love my hotep brothers i
thought they were going to be cussing me
out dude nah man
i mean probably some people i'm sure
somebody's cussing me out
no i think people dig it spacewolf says
what most don't seem to realize about
civil conflict
is that the target will not be uh will
not be just people but infrastructure
industry and resources of our economy
a dozen men cause 911 how does it take
uh how many does it take to poison a
water supply etc
that's crazy that's true you think about
poke yeah
michael says you should take a look at
eviction moratoriums in democrat states
i don't know if you know about them but
it's insane by the way i love the show
keep it the good work oh thank you will
do
dropping gems let's see we got we got
way too many superstitions meditate so
many
sort of sort of yeah sort of you have to
tap into the better tint pool
oh yeah there's a better tim in there
you have to tap this is a pretty good
one i like him
all right we got super chat lauren says
after suffrage
mediocre lib women needed a cause and
used black trauma as the vector
[ __ ] are the only absolutely wronged
group in america
the japanese internment being next let
uh
white why t women is that white women
will always
be miss miss millie's to me the color
purple
f by pac yt made me edit interesting
i love white women yeah yeah
i like people i like i like i like i
love how white women embrace their
femininity
it's different i love how black women i
said i tweeted the other day i love how
white women embrace their femininity
and a lot of people took it as
disrespect to black women but i love the
way black women embrace their femininity
it's different
it's just completely different i enjoy
the way these different cultures embrace
their femininity
and for someone who hated white people
for so long i'm just now like trying to
learn and love them
and i love but white women you know when
we go look at how they used to be
trafficked
you know back in the days of tammany
hall in new york white women didn't have
it in
too easy in america either yeah a lot of
a lot of people love you man
we're like um different cultures but not
different races
and then we just have different skin
colors but we're just different cultures
sometimes
you ever have you ever noticed that the
only race problem is between white and
black people
that's kind of weird pretty much it's
weird yeah i don't know i don't think
it's the only
thing but i think it's yeah it's the
most highlighted unknown people get
afraid of what they're not familiar with
it can be used
not always they don't but sometimes we
got the super chat here
leor says wow wow wow tim i've never
been more envious of you
i am more envious now than when you had
on the legendary alex jones
hotep jesus i just found out about you
and this short time you have gained a
fan
yes very cool yeah we win love it yes
dip dap dupidy says please invite shuan
head or chris raygun to come on the show
uh i yes
yeah we'll invite anyone right well uh
i'll just i'll say shu's been invited
but she was honest
uh chris reagan i'll invite whatever he
has really bad anxiety i do remember
that oh really yeah i wish he would but
but she was she was got an open invite
remind me to tell you the cure for
depression
before we leave okay the cure what is it
i know uh creativity
health i think it's right oh colleen
noir says great discussion
oh snap yeah that's the super chat room
yeah
no way jim hoff's dragon breath does
that cure depression
oh i've not heard this femme hoff is the
dude that runs around in the arctic cold
with his
feet yes yes i have heard of him richard
nibble says hey tim
my first time seeing you was on joe
rogan's show where you absolutely
dismantled
jack dorsey and i've been hooked
listening to you since i've never
donated to anyone
within your line of work before but i
truly appreciate what you do cheers to
my favorite milk toast defense sitter
hey appreciate it man
tim's a hero i don't know man i'm just
someone who complains about his feelings
on the internet you're a hero you're my
hero
oh that's nice why is that well thanks
for the beating yeah he brought you a
beanie i mean
who else would invite me to their home
to record i don't know i don't know i'd
follow you on twitter
it's like i was saying earlier on i'm
like uh most of the people we have
on it's usually like oh it's i know that
guy from twitter and he says smart stuff
yeah okay
well you're my hero man because nobody
else is going to give me a big platform
to speak to you
rogan he's my hero too
i accept that thank you for the
compliment yeah it's like you and rogan
are my heroes
wow i need murals of you two now jesus
in my home it's gonna be like tupac
malcolm x tim poole and joe rogan that's
right you're slowly getting
i mean there's a lot we disagreed on you
know yeah and that's beautiful
i think so i agree absolutely i agree
with that we're supposed to disagree
we're not supposed to completely agree
all the time it's boring
yeah that would be that would suck stale
i would suck because you balance me out
you keep me grounded and i i elevate you
all right i'm i'm i'm gonna read this
one do it i'm just gonna
is it hard but i'm not gonna say who
it's from because someone said i would
pee on ian
no you're lying come on stop it
don't run into that person what have i
manifested what have you
seen you did see what you did you're
right about saying these things
ian joseph aaron says have y'all seen
shelby steele's new movie who killed
michael brown what are your thoughts if
you have i haven't seen it no
have you heard of it at all no not me
neither
i'm in a bubble i'm in a tech bubble get
out man i just work on my big coins
yeah you got a bitcoin company yeah
coinbatap.com super cool
super cool we we we bring boomers to
bitcoin cool
that's hot that's a good market it's a
great market
you think bitcoin is going to hit 300
and something k no uh
they're just pumping i mean at some
point not this year i mean you might
have
all-time highs of 30k max but 300k is
just absurd
they said what jp morgan said by like
the end of 2021
300k 300k yeah they're trying to get
people got
and then they're gonna sell yeah yeah
you're gonna see another tank after this
they're gonna they're gonna rally it up
sell it then it collapses and they're
gonna buy it back
yeah the best thing to do is dollar cost
average if you dollar cost average you
you would have made a boatload you know
when i said it on coinbitsap.com and i
set it i forget it
it'll just take you know let's say 100
bucks a week out of my account or 50
bucks or 10 bucks whatever your budget
is
they just take it out of your account
and buy bitcoin at whatever price it is
that week you want to hear a funny story
what's that
2011. i'm sitting in my friend's
hackerspace i'm on my computer
and i come across bitcoin it was at 75
cents per bitcoin i had five grand
chilling
because i'd saved up for my job and i
was like
i want to i when this man is nine years
ago so i'm in my i'm like 24 or 25
and i'm thinking like i got to do what
rich people do like i got to invest or
something right
so i look at my buddy and i was like hey
did you see this bitcoin thing yeah i
was like it's 75 cents i could get like
6
000 something right now and he goes dude
don't do it man
it's going to be a scam you're going to
buy it up and then it's going to be just
like worth nothing
and i was like yeah and then i didn't
buy it he might have been right
i would have had six thousand something
i know he might have been in a different
dimension
it's not even that it's my buddy saying
dude don't spend your savings on some
random thing
that's awesome the only question that
remains is did you pee on his head
no did you oh and that's the worst part
did you pee on his arm nice hand i don't
want this out there guys
i don't like stop it all right we got
wait wait we got some more super chips
we got some more switches will charlton
says no u.s marine here i actually love
america
mainly because of the constitution which
i swore an oath to protect
love you tim lydia ian and hotep well
thank you
i'm not going to respond i think all i
want to say is thank you for serving our
country
sir but i i believe that people who are
in the military
have that mindset that's that's that's
part of the
yeah it's part of being yeah it's part
of your job you got to believe in the
country
alan brady says loving the stream so far
hey chad i'm pulling you on if you want
to see tim poole
bring on chris chapel from china
uncensored i do also if you don't
recognize the name or the channel go
discover it it's very good
i mean i'd be down there's a there's a
bunch of youtubers who cover china that
i really would love to have on yeah
but it's getting it's getting crazy
because they're doing all the lockdowns
now
who's doing the lockdowns all these all
these states on the east coast like new
jersey new york
countries dude and then we're probably
gonna yeah in these countries too so
it's getting harder and harder like i
thought things were gonna ease up
because i want to get sargon and count
dankill out here but
i can't cause the lockdowns that would
be epic yeah those guys are great yeah
super fun
yeah fun fun guys big thinkers i like
them all right see we got here
josh cruz says best tim cass by far
people with different opinions sitting
down and having a genuine conversation
and listening to each other's point of
view and not getting angry when someone
disagrees
america america could accomplish
anything if all people were like this
yeah i think i i think so too because
like even when you say something i want
to say agree with we all have a laugh
we'll talk and joke about it and
figure it out yeah man i think the minds
in this room should be the government of
the united states of america just us
just us for
we yeah yeah i think so the council the
council of
timcast irl featuring hotep jesus yes
yep okay i just want to control the army
i'll uh i'll take um
finance i guess what do you want what do
you want to eat i'll be the president
you'll be the president
i'll do whatever you guys need no i'll
be secretary of state no he's he said
he's the military right yeah secretary
of state yes i guess that does make
sure that you have a commander general
he's the secretary of state i control
the women
i'll be the supreme court she says she's
going to control them you won't be
secretary of state women
that's right i'm in charge i'm aunt
lydia you're welcome
i'll control the women that's right good
luck guys
feminists are going to lose oh we got
someone we got someone's got a criticism
they say
violence that's white people from a guy
who said every kid should have a gun and
a diaper when they're born
that was someone who remembered that i
like that he's absolutely right though
right like here i am saying that we're
not naturally violent but another
hand i'm like yo have a gun everybody
should have a gun from the diaper right
right
so can i explain myself yeah of course i
don't want somebody else having a
monopoly
on violence but it's not about having a
gun because i want to shoot somebody
it's about having a gun because i don't
want to get shot
i'm a believer in peace and what do you
call a really big gun
you call it a peacekeeper that's right
yeah it's called a peacekeeper
when you talk about going to war they
call it peacekeeping yeah
right yeah but they're trying to i
but my point is there's nuance to this
conversation
we are at a certain level of
consciousness and at the level of
consciousness
guns are a thing and at the current
state of consciousness it's not fair to
have a monopoly on guns but that's not
to say that
our original purpose or we were
you know inherently violent i don't
agree with those are two separate things
i think that's just the state of our
consciousness
we got another super chat for you though
bailly and says tim nah man you need to
challenge him more on that hotep
you need to go read about the tutsi
massacre in africa literally turned on
their neighbors and massacre them
massacre them humans are dark period
jocko had a podcast on it it's brutal
people always talk about the tootsies
yeah so i didn't bring them up for a
reason what's your reasoning i mean
what happens when you destabilize an
entire continent exactly
that's what it is it's white people yeah
that's what i was thinking all right we
got a super chat
rarity says hi tim hi lydia hi hotep
y'all are cool af
ian is just regular cool also i hate to
get off topic what kind of deck did you
run when you played magic
uh i got a bunch of decks right now
mostly commander so
i don't know tomorrow tarot cards will
you mention together
it's a it's a it's a strategy game oh
like uh dungeon and dragons
i mean kind of it's like but it's uh you
have a deck of cards you draw them and
you
the cards do things so it's it's the
superpowers it's like chess and poker
combined that's the way interesting
so it's like it's really fun yeah yeah
yeah there's five you throw fireballs or
yes fireball's a red spell that you can
cast yeah there's red white
black green and blue magic and they all
kind of like red it's fire chaos and
who's gm there's no it's just it's like
the cards it's like chess oh that's
interesting so it's like it's like chess
and poker combined so you're playing
turn base back and forth
but instead of just a row of pieces
you've got a deck of 60 or 100 cards
like pokemon cards yeah yeah
i like that sounds like fun it is fun it
is fun
i'm in a white boy [ __ ] like that but
but a lot of people a lot of people need
to understand that when it comes to
magic
most people who play it aren't playing
it because it's it's themed like wizards
and stuff right
they're playing it because it's like
chess okay it doesn't matter that the
card you have is like warrior knight or
whatever it's just like
the card has this value the card does
this thing and then you calculate and
strategize against your opponent
okay don't describe it as chess i play
chess it's nothing like chess no it is
uh well okay
it's it's in the sense of a turn-based
strategy game but with cards okay it's
more like cards at random
not necessarily you build your deck and
so you don't get the same deck every
time
in chess you get the same pieces
everywhere that's why that's why that's
why it's like poker as well
but with with 60 cards you've got 20
which are resource cards then you have
40 and then you have four of each for
the most part so it's
typically predictable i gotcha but
there's a lot of
pro magic players who are also pro poker
players
there was there was an old joke back
when i was when i was younger playing
magic they said
the reason why that is in poker you're
trying to figure out what your opponent
has
out of 52 cards and magic you're trying
to figure out what your opponent has out
of 13
000. and you can also calculate the odds
of what you're going to draw if you're
counting cards
yeah there's a lot of stuff like that
yeah say it's like chess 960 because
chestnut 60 is random 960 is cool yeah i
never played it though but i read about
it yeah
bobby fischer wanted to make things you
know spice it up right
bub savvy says the range of human
morality is not exclusive to anyone race
you have to empower the individual
before you can expect anything from the
collective
here's absolutely correct so let me
clarify earlier i said that's white
people stuff
and the reason why i said that is
because it's mostly white books that say
that
like white authors usually in the hotep
community
we don't write that into existence
or you'll hear white people say and
that's why i say that's white people-ish
yeah because i only hear it from i mean
i'm gonna hear it from black people of
course
because they've been indoctrinated by
the white liberal but that's literally
some white liberal haunted mifflin
mcgraw-hill taught stuff right
in mifflin yeah i remember those books
man yeah the the conquest
wrote a lot of the the winner writes the
history basically and
the conquerors came and wrote a bunch of
history what about art of war
oh yeah tribal warfare what about it i
mean there's a lot of stuff about
violence and war
it comes from what's the best way to win
the war according to sun tzu
the best you went before you started win
the war before going to war
but if you run out of water that's when
i think it all comes from running out of
a water supply and then the tribe next
door would run out of water and then
they'd come over and take your water and
that's kind of troubling yeah japan was
crazy i was watching i watched a youtube
video about like the history of japan
and how it became like unified
brutal mm-hmm just like constantino
period the world
what it was yeah the 1400s tokugawa and
oto crazy stuff vicious brutal stuff you
want to hear a funny story yeah
so i went to uh south korea i went to
seoul i went to this museum
where they were explaining their like
great job like they were highlighting
this great general
and i was like oh it's really cool i'm
gonna learn about like you know korean
history and stuff
and so they have like this one display
where it shows this like amazing fleet
of like
korean vessels going up against the
japanese and it was like and he was
victorious and he
he won then you go to like the next
slide and it was like in the next great
battle he won but now he's got way less
ships
and the japanese have like the same
amount and i was like wait a minute
out of like so all of these slides it
eventually ends with like his final
great battle it's like two ships left
and the japanese love the same
and i was like so they did was out of a
hundred battles where he won three of
them they highlighted those as the great
victories of their general when he was
getting crushed by the japanese fleets
yeah i thought that was funny they got
it they got a pro you know they got to
be proud about something right
the best the best place to um to
understand the world is within
yourself agreed all right tom mee says
i appreciate your honesty ty thank you
very cool
chuck uh chuck says tim why don't you
have a law enforcement officer on
i'd love to yeah yeah let's we'll get
one on
sparky the sparky the pyro says still
here advocating for trump buying cnn
then sitting back and watching the media
world implode
also keep it the good work fighting
against the lies and shining flood
lights
and the garbage trump tv coming soon do
you think so i don't know if i believe
it i believe it
yeah yeah it's a very smart move yeah
speak that into existence
trump tv trump tv trump tv yes trump tv
it flows i think he should buy cnn they
wouldn't
do it they wouldn't let him do it no
they wouldn't put it up for sale it's
too much power
well there's no i mean that's the rumor
going around that dates for sale 18t is
150 billion dollars in debt and cnn is a
money pit
now that i'll put it this way now that
they think trump's on
on the way out maybe he is it seems most
like very likely i'm waiting for the
electoral college but we'll see
but uh their golden goose is gonna be
gone what are they gonna do
yeah we're gonna talk about trump you
know everybody's gonna go back to
talking about whatever they're talking
about before politics became pop culture
i don't i don't know
vox ezra klein and matthew iglesias have
quit yeah
there's three founders the only founder
left is melissa bell
another two have left matthew iglesias
went independent
as recline went to the new york times
right after the election they knew
they were like if trump loses our
companies won't exist buzzfeed just
bought huffington post
grifton's season is over i know right
shout out to uncle hotel
griffin season that's exactly what we
were talking about man this season
people understand you know when it's a
good season to grift and one is not
these people man i'm gonna keep doing my
thing i'm gonna keep hanging out with
people we're gonna talk about stuff i'm
looking for good
i'm looking forward to policies going
away dude your grift is good
it's my grift is good it's good
how are we defining grift here we're
using it very loosely
like there's a there's a there's two
types of girth according to me
okay there's one that gives back and
there's one that doesn't
okay right so ourselves so where you can
grift but you're not a grifter now a
grifter doesn't give back they just take
from the culture
right and raising money and you know for
all these little hashtags and they steal
and you know whatever whatever
that's a grifter now when we grift it's
like
we know we have to talk about grind we
grind right right so yeah but we know we
have to talk about some things that
might not we probably wouldn't talk
about in our personal lives we were like
no
that's not gonna talk about all this
stuff i i
there's a lot of topics that come across
my desk i just wouldn't talk about
in my personal life and i just cover
them because people go hotep jesus what
do you think about this
yeah yeah and so you have to cover it
it's my duty to cover it that's not
grifton
you know griffin is like when you lie
about someone to generate some kind of
clicks you know what i mean right that's
what i said it's nuanced to this right
we're very playful with it
but it it it uh for the media that
season is over
i'm looking forward to fighting
president i'm looking forward to the
lockdowns being over and for politics to
be outside of this so i can go back to
talking about
cultural issues and movies yeah i don't
know
you know what you know what i did i
remember this like a year and a half ago
i had a segment it was about
a guy was outside of a bar and two women
were fighting and then the woman hits
the guy
the guy hits her back and that and then
everyone starts attacking the guy and
the guy runs off and gets arrested later
on
that was it that was the segment i was
like man this is crazy why isn't like
this happening
i have a video that's got like almost
two million views it's about why men
aren't helping women and children
just a cultural issue thing and then all
of a sudden everything just became
completely front page dominated by
donald trump
yeah and so now it's all politics all
the time that's the pop culture like you
said politics is pop culture yeah
i love talking about culture like we've
been doing it's so much more like
we're getting so much more out of it
than talking about trump and biden
i feel like i want to talk about
levitating let's do levitating you and
ian would get along
let me read this super chat real quick
your favorite sociologist says
inter-tribal war existed since the
beginning of us it is why we moved from
the area of our development populations
grew and conflicts arose
arab raids happened centuries before
whites arrived stop the
oversimplification it helps nobody
so let's see arab the arab the arab
conquering
of africa is what led to the
destabilization
in fact the europeans couldn't conquer
until they brought christianity
at first it was dominated by the islamic
caliphate
he's actually very correct in that but i
grew up i grew up all y'all together
so we're work as an ignorant hotep
we got one more super chat one more time
we got we got a super chat i got to read
tom mee says biden will provide enough
material
i don't know biden's going to be hiding
haydn biden's going to be in the
basement he's not going to say anything
material for who for people to talk
about i guess
i mean sure the that's what the right's
going to do they're going to grift off
of biden and just complain about him
like people can play they're already
starting
i'm seeing it it's great i'm loving it
yeah so so now i'm seeing these
progressives who used to post on
facebook all day
trump is bad now all of a sudden going
joe biden's appointing lobbyist to his
transition team what's happening and i'm
like
here it comes and you know what fine you
know what i said to him i was like so
does this mean you're gonna start
watching my content again
because now like not conservatives and
progressives are gonna be mad at biden
i'm gonna be talking about the same
stuff now they're gonna come around they
deserve that they deserve to they
deserve to watch
what they voted for the founder yo
that's what you've
done joe biden's gonna gonna walk come
on man we gotta put more troops in syria
yeah we're gonna be like oh great yeah i
know yeah yeah
so i'm gonna be like here we go and then
the progressions are going to come
around and be like hey we're mad again
remember when when jank yogurt the young
turks said joe biden had dementia
yeah in march yeah it was politically
convenient because he wanted to support
bernie
then when it went to biden he was all
for biden now it's like
give it give you know look joe biden
gets inaugurated the progressives are
going to come around in two seconds
yeah they're going to be like bite it's
terrible and i'm going to be like
i agree because i've been saying that
for quite some time yeah i'm just going
to be
building ai and bitcoin apps that's a
good thing to do man
you know what we're going to do we're
starting this vlog we're going to be
skating i think we got someone who might
come in to do the vlog
and we're just going to skate hang out
play music have fun and i want to make
sure that
we can kind of bring back some levity
you know some some chills some music
some comedy
look at the last four years the
conservatives spent the entire time
running behind whatever the left was
complaining about they still do like the
other day they were talking about harry
styles and the dress
yeah and i'm like you're behind yeah i'm
like why would i even talk about that
right dude if that's what vogue and him
want to do then
great you know but you know the
conservatives they you know some of the
prominent ones they took that and
trended and did their thing and i'm like
you know that works for you
but for what conservatives are trying to
get to when we say these celebrities are
not important we have to completely
remove them from the consciousness
distraction
yeah we have to completely remove those
distractions and and and keep that stuff
outside of our bubble
and talk about the things we want to
talk about if the nuclear family
is under attack then we talk about how
mom can
love children better how how while
they're talking about harry styles in
the dress we're over here addressing
real life stuff
or skating or tech yeah let's just have
these conversations and let other people
talk about what they want to talk about
i'm not talking about harry styles in a
dress good for him
if he's happy i'm happy for him right
dude exactly
i see that stuff and i'm like i don't i
don't think anything of it at all right
i saw that whole fiasco the trend with
like candace owens and ben shapiro
and i was just like i mean she's not
lying right she told i feel i agree with
what she said what she said is very much
truthful right
like i agree with the marxist agenda is
no coincidence that there
is both of those things happening at the
same time yeah but at the same time it's
like
why are we talking about it yeah yeah
seriously yeah especially right now with
everything that's going on with the
election
yeah instead of talking about him let's
talk about somebody who's macho
mm-hmm or just yeah
people can talk about whatever they want
i talk about what i feel like talking
about you know we didn't get to that
anyway it's uh it's 10 30 we went over
quite a bit but
this is great well
about what i just know you're going to
say something yeah i just want to say
um i say a lot of inflammatory things to
make people
jump right and i do that on purpose
like for example i said i group the
arabs and the white people together
i don't mean that i'm joking right
i mean that in some ways as in first the
arabs came and invaded our [ __ ] then
y'all came along right so
i can group you don't look at me in that
in that you know
manner but the one thing we have to
understand is that
the divide between black and white
people has been
used for so long the first divide was
between white men and natives
white men realized how crappy this
country was
and they started defecting and started
going to live with the natives
and then they were like all right for
every white man you catch hanging with
the natives catch them
and you scalp them that's where the
scalpel really started yeah
it was the government versus them people
were deserting they were like yo
i'm hungry here under these colonies
and the natives i'm eating good and
pocahontas sexy so you know i'm over
here
but again that was at that story
basically it wasn't huh was it john
smith
yeah john smith right yeah then the
seminoles
in in florida i encourage people to go
look at that history and how they
pit native against native native against
white man do you know about the little
apple of death
what's that so i went on a uh uh what do
they call it's like
it's like you go down the canals in
florida there are these trees
it's actually in spanish i can't
remember the name of spanish it's like
you know why i say apple
in spanish monsanto yeah it's like uh
la manzanita de los muertos or something
like that
there were these trees that have this
toxin on them
and what the natives down there would do
was when they were capturing a prisoner
or something or a prisoner of war or
combatant they would time the tree and
leave them there
and then when it rains the water would
wash the toxins down it would sweep over
people
and it would just you'd be trapped there
with your skin burning from the toxins
and there was like people would eat them
because they taste they would be like oh
and they'd eat it then
yeah dude yeah if you touch the tree you
get like reaction it's crazy
yeah so you know people have always used
other people for example when they
imported
um irish and italians
to undercut the labor market
that was controlled by wasps then they
used black people
to cut the the picket lines
they've always used divide and conquer
against us
what we got to do is we got to stop
feeding into that man
you know um my ancestors a lot of them
were into anti-whiteness i'm not into
anti-anti-whiteness
i understand that the the best thing to
destroy this machine is white and black
unity
that's why there's that meme of the two
hands coming together white and black
and it says the one thing they fear the
most
that's the one thing they fear we're not
actually white and black too which is
something i think about a lot like i'm
kind of pinkish
you're more brown than black if and your
skin i don't even talk about you right
the skin tone right it's like so like
the words aren't even accurate anyway
right
correct and and and white really means
free and black mean slaves yeah
you know how weird i grew up on the
south side of chicago
and i can tell you there were you meet
all kinds
like i know so many white crackheads
that just like fell in the gutter and
lived in the gutter
and it was just like it's it's one it's
really hard to be racist when you've got
people of all different races
and there's no pattern to be discerned
between them based on their races well
think about or how they look or their
skin color think about history right
they said the majority of the population
of black folk was living down south
and they were legislating how you
treated black people down south
well where are all the black people up
north if y'all so not racist how come
you don't have black people around
yeah and how come when people were freed
and they came up north
they said they missed the south and
there were still there was still
there were still problems with civil
rights when they came up north not only
did they have to not deal with civil
rights they had to deal with the
the puritan philosophy and how
you know snooty the people of the north
were my point being
um the the thing that that is happening
right now
and i warn conservatives do not allow
black lives matter to
to make you think that that's how the
consciousness of black people operate
the consciousness of black people is
very loving the consciousness of white
people is very loving
or european and african you know or
caucasian and african whatever the terms
we're going to use but that that
that that first seed that's planted is
love is not fear and it's not violence
it's love and we have that within us
and and and and to point to your point
you're saying the government is the
reason why people aren't killing each
other and i think the reason why people
aren't killing each other because people
are full of love
and people don't have it in them to kill
another person people don't have it in
them
to kill a deer or a cow to make their
meal
they couldn't physically do it it takes
a lot to kill somebody you know so i
think there's more good in humanity
than bad and i just wanted conservatives
when you see black lives matter you
can't say on one hand it's george soros
and then be like why do black people on
first of all black people are not on a
democrat plantation that's another thing
i have to destroy right now
my aunties might be on a democrat
you have to understand that the black
you know boomers and on
are the primary voters right and they're
going to be
down ballot but as they die off you see
it with trump's presidency
more black voters came out and voted for
it yeah dude because as that
voting block dies off you're getting
more and more free thinkers and people
that work you gotta remember the boomer
class was born with tvs everything that
comes out of the tv they think is real
right right they think everything comes
out that thing is real so we got to
understand it's not
the black community is not on the
democratic plantation half of us 50
of us don't vote period and don't
believe in voting they don't mess with
biden or trump
and the people that are voting are dying
voting block
right on man well dude thanks for coming
it's been great oh thank you for having
me my
sure dude any time yeah uh was excited
that we were able to get you to come
down
especially considering covet a lot of
people don't want to come but dude uh
yeah man for sure i'm a soldier
you want to mention your social media or
your show or anything like that um
you know i'm black we gotta give shout
outs yo shout out to uncle hotep
shout out to dodu shout out to michael
green shout out to lauren literally
shout out to chad
shout out to brody ken the row raider
sketch therapy hotep nation oh i got an
ai company
shout out to wazo ai right on we do
camera vision
uh tech analytics what is what is it
exactly
uh basically anything that fronts uh
comes in front of a camera we can create
data and analytics
uh from it really yeah we were talking
about getting like um a context
over like a context um what would you
call it you put it in your browser like
a
browser augmentation where you could
tell if a video comes from a larger
video
ooh yeah yeah yeah you can definitely do
something like that
uh you would probably need to api or
something to the internet but
yeah that's definitely possible with
machine learning you got a podcast
yes hotel's been told you every thursday
8 pm eastern time
me and uncle hotep is hot
right on yeah what about twitter you got
twitter right twitter hotep jesus
right on man um main websites
hotepnation.com that's where we operate
from
um yeah but thank you for having me man
no for sure good man you know
hey i appreciate it dude thanks for
coming and of course you can follow me
on twitter instagram parlor at tim cast
you can check out my other youtube
channels youtube.comtimcast
youtube.comcastnews the show is live
monday through friday at 8pm
and make sure you like subscribe hit the
notification bell yeah really smash that
like button on your way out
you can also follow this guy over here
yes at ian crossland amongst
most in all of the social networks and
share this thing too did you already say
that share this thing oh no i don't
yeah you could say that one time your
friends tell them about it if you like
it
and we're also on uh itunes and all that
stuff itunes uh spotify so you can
if you if you end up missing one of the
live shows just we we upload it almost
immediately
actually it's lydia who does it you can
follow her as well yeah you can follow
me on
twitter at sourpatchlidslyds right now
hey real quick we talked a lot about
human politics and the politics of
animals but can we just give a shout out
to this plant yes i was gonna go there
next
this beautiful creature amazing
levitating and spinning endlessly
amazing everyone should have a plant yes
look at it just spinning
so soothing anyway thanks for hanging
out everybody we'll be back what's today
friday
yeah oh man i got a weekend off half
days technically so uh monday will be
uh at 8 pm thanks for hanging out and we
got some really really
important guests coming up next week
it's going to be serious pretending the
election and stuff so stick around
we will see you monday at 8pm thanks for
hanging out bye guys
you